the new mass guidelines are out if
you've gotten your vaccine your full
vaccine you don't got to wear a mask
anymore and
something weird has happened democrats
and leftist personalities don't want to
take their masks off
and this resulted in almost
i want to call it a fight i was i was
fighting with myself like should we say
fight because because basically a
staffer for marjory taylor green yells
to eric swalwell you know democrat from
the bay area biden says you can take
your mask off and then swallow gets in
his face says don't you tell me what the
thing do and then all of a sudden
everyone's like oh it's huge news
they're fighting
and then swalwell's like don't bully
people who wear masks and i just find it
very very strange how tribal the whole
thing is but
this is it's a bigger story just beyond
the mask thing because as many of you
know
there are real serious ramifications for
the covert restrictions the people
who've been arrested
the people whose businesses have been
shut down and more importantly the
people who lost their lives not just
from the pandemic but the people who
were literally killed by andrew cuomo
and many of these other governors who
were warned not to put sick people into
these nursing homes so we've got a lot
to talk about a lot of it's gonna be a
bit serious we're gonna talk about these
guidelines where we're currently at and
what's going on with the cuomo thing
because my friends i mean it looks like
he's getting away with it we have a very
special guest we have the legendary
janice dean hanging out
you didn't want me to give to mention a
title or anything so you can introduce
yourself
i'm just janisteen and i'm happy to be
here but people are going to want to
know what you do
i'm the weather person i'm the
meteorologist the broadcast
meteorologist on fox and friends and
i've been at fox now for 18 years wow
right and so that's my primary job
although i am in baltimore uh for the
preakness for the horse race cool
because i love watching the horses and
there's a controversy right now i don't
know if you've read the news about bob
baffert who uh who has the kentucky
derby winner medina spirit
uh he is probably the legendary trainer
when it comes to horse training uh he's
had two triple crowns he's had the most
uh
wins in terms of kentucky derby winners
medina spirit and the latest news is
medina spirit did not pass a drug test
after the kentucky derby
there's a very very very small amount of
i think it's like a cordus steroid or
cortico
in the bloodstream after the race and so
immediately after
well i guess they did a test right after
uh and they had done tests beforehand
but in kentucky
that particular state that substance is
banned but in other states it's not
interesting interesting so uh the big
deal was uh that the horse you know uh
is drugged or that's what the media
wants to tell you we should talk about
it we should talk about that there's a
more serious topic though that i i don't
know if you want to mention immediately
having to do with cuomo we can
you don't want to be as strong as i did
when i talk about cuomo literally
killing people but
well it's interesting that you say that
because
i
you know i get a little bit nervous
about it i don't know if we can prove
that he has killed all these people i
will tell you as someone who
has relatives my husband's parents
were in separate elder care facilities
they both died of covid
and not hearing uh the fact that the
governor was putting over 9 000 coveted
positive patients into nursing homes we
weren't hearing that on television the
nursing homes didn't tell us that
so i became vocal
when i kept seeing the governor on cnn
with his brother and the cuomo brothers
comedy hour not talking about the
nursing home issues and instead you know
talking about the love gov and the fact
that he has a book coming out and uh
somebody threw a big banner over a
highway cuomo killed my mother right
something like that yeah so uh we'll get
into all that and we'll you know and
that's a serious topic for having me
absolutely ian he's chilling i do not
have an emmy like cuomo does
i guess i am here or a book on how to
how to uh effectively manage a pandemic
not yet in the middle of failing to
manage
yet
you could maybe i will actually let's
have a conversation i think you'd
actually be better at managing it
than him i think i agree i mean yeah
anybody would right a five-year-old it's
just it's this cult oh that's my chair
uh are you sure yeah
it's rubber
i don't know what would you call
nepotism the name cuomo got these guys
jobs i feel like i don't necessarily
think he's that great and he says he's
not part of that whole political system
he says that he's not
part of being a cuomo in the political
world man yeah that's cool we'll we'll
we'll uh we'll tell them what for okay
we got lydia pressing buttons i am
pushing buttons in the corner i'm so
excited to have this lady we had a great
drive from baltimore it was a lot of fun
just chatting and i'm excited for this
conversation but before we get started
head over to timcast.com and become a
member you can click this members only
button and then sign up with stripe or
paypal then go to the members area and
we have a huge library of tons of
amazing content only available to our
members we do have one free bit of
content with dave smith and ian talking
about the federal reserve so become a
member
in the event that we get suspended
banned purged or whatever this is where
you'll find our content
however if you just want to support our
work help us expand and make more stuff
new stuff new shows become a member to
help support the work but don't forget
to like share subscribe hit the
notification bell if you're listening on
itunes or spotify leave us a good review
give us five stars
before we go absolutely nuclear i wanted
to kind of warm up a little bit because
like talking about cuomo killing a bunch
of people is pretty intense that is yeah
so we have this story about the cdc
guidelines and the masks and i guess the
big news is that a mask dispute prompts
heated exchange between rep swalwell and
marjorie taylor green aide swalwell said
the aide yelled at him demanding he take
his mask off so quote i told the bully
what i thought of his order all right
first of all there was a reporter there
i think for the hill i'm not sure
who said that marjorie taylor green's
staffer said biden says you can take
your mask off that's what the reporter
said and then swallow got in his face
said don't you tell me what to effing do
and then he went on twitter and said
don't bully people who are wearing masks
or something
now we see this tweet from david hogg
did you see i don't i don't know if you
saw this i have not david hogg said i
feel the need to continue wearing my
mask outside even though i'm fully
vaccinated because the inconvenience of
having to wear a mask is more than worth
it to have people not think i'm a
conservative
i want to throw the masks in the garbage
burn the masks i mean yeah it's done
isn't it i feel that way i mean didn't
biden just say yesterday that we could
we could take them off
right in certain you got your vaccine i
did have the vaccine are we going to
talk about the oh oh um ladies and
gentlemen because we are the bastion of
real journalists right
we were uh we were talking before the
show with janice about these silly
videos where people have magnets and
they put them on their arms
and then i you suggested it you you like
should we try it i'm like if you want to
put a magnet on your arm so
we're going to debunk these ridiculous
videos in real time with janistein who
has a magnet right and you're gonna put
it on your heart yeah i i did have the
the uh pfizer vaccine i don't feel it
like
it's just doing anything yanking okay
i think that's where they put it right
yeah right yeah on the arm shoulder
let's just just in case it was this arm
because i don't well you got to let go
oh it's gonna it just it just
sleeps
people are gonna screenshot it like that
proves it
no yeah um it's not a strong enough and
what should be surprising to absolutely
no one
people's arms are not magnetized by
getting a vaccine
but how many people watched that video
yeah
i think they went fairly viral people
believe
absolutely crazy stuff and it's a bummer
you know we have a lot of guests come
through here a lot of them are trump
supporters
a lot of them don't like the idea of
emergency ethos or authorization or
vaccine passports but a lot of them got
the vaccine and are like look there's a
difference between you having a choice
to go out and decide what you want to do
what's best for you and then having the
government say what you have to do or
having
now
back back to the mask topic
in new york city's new york state cuomo
is like we're not going to release the
mask mandate
it's control it's because he wants to
control it
right don't tell me what to do
if you see some of his press conferences
and you tell him well you said don't
tell me i said that even though he
probably said that
it's funny because he's saying don't
tell me tell me what to do while we're
saying don't tell me what to do
it's the difference of
he's not saying don't tell me what to do
in a sense he's saying don't tell me
what to do with my kingdom right
well remember remember when the vaccines
first came out he didn't want them right
because they were under trump right he
basically said no no we we don't have
any proof uh these vaccines work and so
therefore i don't believe in them this
is the funniest thing about uh the
vaccine thing to me is that
i i find most conservatives you know if
you look at like ben shapiro their their
main talking point is the government
should force people to do it and vaccine
passports are overreached
but you have a lot of people some of the
staunchest trump supporters who are very
much anti like vaccine i i don't think
it's necessarily necessarily fair to say
anti-vaxxer in the sense that most of
the criticism is with it's a new mrna is
new it's emergency use and i think it's
fair for people to say out you know i'll
talk to my doctor i'll just say what's
best for me
but there's there's a decent amount of
people
who are
supporting donald trump and demanding he
get credit for operation warp speed for
getting the vaccine done and then going
like i'm not taking that crazy thing are
you nuts right it's not everybody but it
exists all right and then you have
people on the left who are like the
whole time what was it i think kamala
harris cuomo were critical saying oh no
you know we don't have the research for
this we're not going to do it now that
biden's president they're all giving
them a standing ovation congratulations
on the vaccine good sir and they're not
mentioning trump at all of course not
yeah it was even brought up in a press
conference uh the other day where
someone said to cuomo well the fact that
you don't that people don't want to get
the vaccine don't you attribute to that
to in the beginning you saying that you
didn't believe in the vaccine oh i
didn't say that
some of these people man um i i gotta
say
credit where credit is due uh gretchen
whitmer said the cdc said we're lifting
the mass mandate so we're lifting the
mass mandates
cuomo was like no
he's he's he's obstinate it's it's about
tribe it's about power it's about
i wonder if i mean he's the older
brother isn't he does he have an older
brother than you know no i don't think
so they have a sister and they have
chris the younger brother yeah i'm
wondering if like he was looked over as
a child so he's desperate to assert his
power to like prove something to
somebody
like why can't these people be chill
about it now the cdc said do it you know
whatever all right fine i think he's
always been like that uh i i really do
think that he wanted to be president
someday the fact that his dad never got
to be president i think he kind of took
it upon himself to think that well since
my dad never got there i need to go
there and for a while people were
calling him maybe
uh an alternative to biden did you see
the t-shirts that say homosexual on them
oh my god yeah people went a little over
one of those
[Laughter]
just one
[Laughter]
he even wrote about it in that stupid
book
oh geez the leadership book he he wrote
about the cuomosexuals
i love how he's like use the word in the
middle
of course he did
physically painful i love how he's
writing a book about his success in the
pandemic while he's literally killing
people i thought it was a joke when that
report came out that he was working on a
book a leadership book in the middle of
a pandemic
when thousands of elderly were dying in
nursing homes i thought it was like the
onion or one of those joke webs
yeah but he was actually doing that
you've seen the babylon bee i'm sure
imagine how perfect that headline would
have been yeah governor wright's book on
his successes with the pandemic while
killing the worst governor ever yeah
while killing 50 000 people well here's
the thing though i think that book is
going to be his downfall
they could use that book in a court of
law there are so many lies in it wow
yeah i mean he lied about the nursing
home thing i mean the fact that they
covered up the amount of deaths in the
nursing homes for so long and how that
was debunked by
the new york times that there is all
sorts of information
from his
health department they were going to
release the numbers for many months but
it was it would we were asking for the
total number of deaths while he was
writing that book while he was trying to
sell that four million dollar book
so
the fact that he went above and beyond
his health department and told them not
to release the accurate amount of
numbers
during that time second firm that he
told them not to yes yeah it was it was
covering it up he was warned by these
nursing home experts if you do this you
will kill people and he was like
okay
well i think we have to find out the
origins of the march 25th order why was
it written and not only him you
mentioned
whitmer she had almost the identical
mandate
tom wolf as well tomorrow
and new jersey murphy
and gavin uh gavin newsom yep
maybe they just uh all got together on a
zoom call and we're like let's kill
people
well
i would like to get to the bottom of it
i mean there are several investigations
right now there's a federal
investigation there's an fbi
investigation there's a doj
investigation which started under trump
i'm grateful to bill barr for starting
that because that's the that's the one
that got him all freaked out when they
found out that they the uh the doj was
doing an investigation into nursing
homes and that's when
they realized oh my gosh they you know
they want accurate numbers and that's
when his top aide melissa derosa
in a meeting with democratic lawmakers
closed door said well we froze and we
didn't want to you know we didn't want
to give the information out because you
know that that would prove that that
maybe we had something to hide they were
wasn't it that they were they knew it
would result in an investigation of
course
they were worried that trump would use
it to launch an investigation right
obviously to the numbers and that's why
she took a bunch of democratic lawmakers
into a closed-door meeting to say i'm
really sorry we didn't tell you but you
know we couldn't we couldn't you know
put more fire in into this situation
because you know we didn't want people
to freak out and and what they tried to
spin it as was they didn't want the
trump administration to politicize these
numbers right that he's blamed everyone
he has blamed uh god and mother nature
and the trump administration at one
point he blamed the old people because
they're old and they're gonna die wow
and think about the the the context when
he was like you know donald trump would
have used this
i mean he should have that the people
should have known what you were doing so
they can vote against it because i'm
sure they would have been upset about it
you know what what gets me though is
like why did the new york times go
against cuomo what happened i mean they
they were homosexual and then all of a
sudden they were like down with cuomo
because it not just that not not just
this story all of a sudden all these
accusations started popping up against
them he's still going i mean every time
i think that there is another you know
uh
woman that's going to come forward with
harassment you know actually every time
there was a new woman coming forward
with some of these sexual harassment
allegations he would start to lift
restrictions like okay you know what
restaurants you can have 75 of people to
come in uh and you know now
he's trying to open up new york again
yeah
people have made have mentioned that
with joe biden as well it's been a
really bad week inflation is freaking
everybody out the conflict of elite
conflict in the middle east whitmer
wants to shut down a gas pipeline while
another gas pipeline was hacked and
there's gas shortages even right now and
then biden comes out you can take your
mask off just take them off yeah hey hey
everybody
that changed the new cycle real quick
now now the top story on like a bunch of
websites is like swalwell fighting with
uh with marjory taylor green
i mean they got us distracted a little
bit i gotta admit but but yeah so uh but
but why did the new york times
all of a sudden just come out and be
like
no cuomo
the
ag report uh new york's attorney general
leticia james who is a democrat
released a report in january that
basically did the
uh in investigation to what we've all
wanted which was the the accurate number
of deaths in nursing homes he was go he
wasn't counting those that died in the
hospital like my mother-in-law for
example she got coveted in her assisted
living residence she died in the
hospital but her number did not count he
was the only governor that didn't count
those that died in the hospital and you
can imagine if you're not counting those
that's going to be a significant
percentage of of numbers you're not
admitting to so latisha james did her
own
document uh 76 pages that basically said
he was hiding the numbers and that's
when the dam began to crack and that's
when you started to realize that maybe
he does have enemies
in his own uh party well is leticia
progressive
there are you know there are thoughts
that maybe she wants to run for governor
someday but i'll tell you this much i
don't care what the reasoning is right i
don't care what brings them down either
you know people say to me well what if
it's you know the all these women coming
forward doesn't matter to me as long as
long as something eventually brings them
down and the fact that there are
investigations into the nursing home
issue and more people know about it you
know i feel like
i'm on the side of the angels and
hopefully you know good will prevail you
know it would be great if ocasio-cortez
wins the governorship because cuomo gets
knocked out wouldn't that be amazing
i don't know who should run
his face amazing like a unicorn pooping
rainbows like it's terrifying terrifying
i mean i'm sure there's a lot of people
in the country that would be like
governor c cortes oh kaiser cortez would
be amazing i'm kidding um it would it
would be amazing not in the positive
sense just like i'd be amazing
awesome but
man the democratic party is just like
knives out do you think a republican has
a shot at being the governor of new york
i mean i want to say yes
just because of how awful everything's
been
and if cuomo
uh i'm assuming he can run for
re-election right yes fourth term yeah
is is there gonna be any democrat
powerful enough to knock him out and
primary him or something
i don't know maybe
if if it's possible for a republican win
if it's possible for a republican to win
in new york i bet it's possible for
someone to primary cuomo
with new york city
i'd imagine they probably could get rid
of him
you know they're all going to vote
against him but who could possibly who
could it be i guess is the question
who's got the charisma to to actually
run
if they don't replace cuomo because they
don't have a strong enough candidate
then i think a republican could probably
win because the rest of new york state
is going to be like just enough already
yeah i don't know what that would mean
though i mean that'd be kind of crazy
right when was the last time new york
had pataki
when was that
gosh well that was before him
right and cuomo's been in power for
three terms
so before that that was so not that long
ago yeah all right so then yeah i guess
so possible it is possible well did you
see what uh who who tweeted this was it
robert reich or whatever his name is
where he was like no maybe it wasn't
somebody said
that uh 2022 is the battle for the soul
oh yeah it was someone i didn't
recognize yeah some guy he was like it's
the fight to prove whether this country
falls to white supremacy or something
yeah and i'm like shut up you said that
about 2020 and 2018 and 2016 every
single every two years
but i have to wonder uh the democrats
have a very thin grasp of power right
now i mean the house it's like 11 seats
the senate is literally no seats these
have a tiebreaker with kamala
so if
what we're seeing now with the ratings
on these more progressive uh outlets the
ratings with cnn cnn and msnbc going
down
the democrats have gone back to sleep
the voter base is like disinterested now
that trump is gone
the conservatives the anti-woke the
anti-critical race theory types
disrupted liberals they're active 100
so come 2022
i think we could see a big push for the
republicans to take control of
everything what do you think about gavin
newsom
i think he's awful yeah i do too
but do you think that they have enough
to get rid of them um man
what's the option caitlyn jenner
right now right yeah um who else was
gonna run like randy quaid mentioned he
was gonna run or something i don't know
i don't know well it's a runoff right or
it's uh it's a recall election which
means anyone can put their name in the
in in you know in the in the ring or
whatever and then they need a certain
threshold to win right
the problem right now is you know throw
it back like the mask stuff tribalism
very clearly controls everything
so
caitlyn jenner is
taboo you know all of these people who
came out and celebrated caitlyn jenner
saying you're brave we respect you
you're amazing and powerful
all of a sudden now are like you're evil
and wrong and we must resist it's
they're gonna support gavin newsom
simply because of the tribe they're in
it's the democrats gotta vote democrat
no matter what gotta wear a mask doesn't
matter what cdc says
so gavin newsom might win do you think
most people would take off their mask
yes i do i do
because
you know what actually let me slow down
it's tough i think in the cities
people are
man they they are indoctrinated i don't
know if indoctrinate is the right word
but they are very
terrified terrified i mean it's a better
way to put it
but terrified of what exactly covered
yeah still
sounds like it i mean you look at that
tweet from david hogg he's like i don't
want people to think i'm a conservative
so i'm gonna keep wearing a mask it's
like okay dude whatever oh so that's not
regular people
are gonna take their masks off it's
freedom
yeah but
even even out here so we're we're in the
we're in the part of maryland where it
meets west virginia and virginia we have
that we have the appalachian trail over
here
i was running my bike down there and i
saw people you're in the middle of the
woods you're in the middle of the woods
in west virginia and there's like a guy
running wearing a mask
and i'm like
if you want to fine like i'm not going
to i'm not going to say anything high
altitude training
i guess takes more energy to breathe so
you get stronger
if the logic of the mask was always you
don't want to spit on somebody
i'm like and you're in the middle of the
woods
i if if he hit it around his neck and he
was running and he saw me he pulled it
up i'd be like i get it maybe you guys
can help me here i'm confused bill maher
got the vaccine then he got covered he
just got it came out yesterday and said
that and so he's not doing his [ __ ] the
first time in his career he's missed a
show yeah that's what he was saying i
don't okay so apparently if you get the
vaccine you can still get covet
obviously bill maher
is it that you're less likely to
to give it to someone if you have
received the vaccine no that's not the
case it's that your body can quickly
fight off the infection without causing
you to go through the disease
you're less likely to get symptoms
and asymptomatic spread is possible or
is not possible i don't remember uh
i don't know i'm not a doctor no i don't
know that's something we should probably
know having gone through a pandemic well
it's just that there's been conflicting
reports so that's why i'm always just
like
you know for a lot of things if someone
told me like what do i do if i like
break my arm i'd be like okay well i'm
not a doctor said it if someone if
someone asks for like first aid advice
okay i've done hostile environment
training i can give you some general
first date advice
but this stuff is is contentious tribal
i just say talk to a doctor to figure
out what makes sense and what happened
with bill maher
he got he got sick but he's asymptomatic
because he's been vaccinated
so you can still get it
but you can't like you're not gonna die
from it so i guess the people that got
vaccinated are they still think there's
a chance they might get it and that
people might asymptomatically spread it
so they're putting the mask on just to
be safe i mean honestly i don't know
i think people just don't know and
they're scared i think you're right i
think this whole time
most people did not know what was
happening
they don't well i think
the big divide between you know in the
culture war is what i refer to as the
uninitiated and the initiated the people
who pay attention to politics who watch
the videos and the people who just
passively hear things
so if you're if you're following a lot
of this news you've got a much more
you're probably a lot more relaxed about
everything because you've seen the
reports you've seen the numbers in texas
and florida going down you've seen
voucher's statements and you're probably
like okay i think we're going to be all
right and if you don't pay attention all
you see is masks everywhere and warning
signs and street closures and cities
shut down so you're really scared about
it i think a good example is like kyle
rittenhouse where if you follow
you know we we had we we've had richie
mcginnis here numerous times and i don't
know if you're familiar he's the
journalist who was actually there and
actually rendered aid to the men so he
tells us what happens and we get a clear
picture and we're like oh that's really
interesting but then i hear from people
who don't pay attention to the news kyle
rittenhouse took a gun across state
lines and did all these things like none
of which is true
so they're angry and they have this
distorted view of things
a lot of my friends
uh like i have a really good friend of
mine who's like i want to come and visit
but you know i'm really worried about
traveling and i'm just like whatever
makes sense for you and they're like
once i get my vaccine you know i'll i'll
think if i could i'll figure out if i
can do it or not and i'm like it's by
all means
in terms of the show i'll give you a
better example
i've re there was um i'll just i'll just
mention the people um there's a very
famous leftist hassan [ __ ] he's got one
of the biggest twitch shows he's got a
big youtube channel um
and he's one of the most prominent i
think he's a democratic socialist i
don't want to label people
but uh
i tweeted it's very difficult for us to
get leftists on this show because they
just refuse to do it they're scared of
being cancelled i don't know
and then i had two personalities one of
which was hassan and they tweeted
quote tweeted me saying i'll come on
your show and i was like fantastic yes
dude i mean hassan that should be
awesome i'd be so excited for that he's
he's a popular leftist we'd have great
conversation we probably disagree a lot
of things and uh i said we'll pay for
your travel let me know what dates are
good for you and then he messaged me and
said oh bro covet i can't travel
now now to be fair this was last year
when you know this was like i think
around august or whatever people were a
lot more worried
tons of basically every single leftist
we reached out to said because of covet
i won't travel
last night i was looking but real quick
every single conservative personality
was like where and when no questions no
issues and uh i would say a decent
amount of the conservatives who come got
their vaccine a decent amount didn't and
they say i'll take responsibility for
myself and
for most of the i would say we followed
all the guidelines it wasn't that crazy
out here to follow the guidelines we
have like hand sanitizer we were sure
how many people come in not hard to do
and
conservatives didn't seem to have an
issue with it but people on the left
mortified i was looking um at
michelle it's it's an abbey in france
have you ever heard this place it's like
on an island it was this duchy of like
normandy and it's this beautiful giant
island monastery and i was like oh i
want to go there i can just go there for
a weekend and check it out and then i
i was like oh yeah coveted
i just what a hassle like you gotta i
don't even know what france's
regulations are standing in line being
around them in my mask am i vaccinated
what like i just gave it all up i can't
i feel like i can't even travel because
you can't
we went to aruba a couple weeks ago with
my family but we had to jump through
hoops to do it but i was like you know
what i'm done you know we've had a
terrible year with loss in our family
you know you talk about
us in covid but the kids my children
12 years old 10 years old wearing those
masks in school
when there's hardly any risk for them to
get it going outside for a 10-minute
mask break uh not being able to
socialize with their friends having
plastic around their desks
it is
soul crushing
i think what people need to realize
about their kids too is that
i think you know we're all a bit older
so for us we've experienced so much our
personalities have formed we've become
mature adults to someone who's 10 years
old a day is a lot longer
because they're forming these
experiences they're developing into the
people they'll become in the future
so when you take a year which is a tenth
of a 10 year old's life 10 percent of
their life and you turn it into this
thing
that's going to affect them for the rest
of their lives i know it has my 10 year
old i feel it i know it he every day you
know mom when is it over this is the
worst year of my life yes yes
i mean and it manifests itself in
different ways you know
we had a
we had this little fish this betta fish
for like eight months and we loved it
and the betta fish unfortunately died
but my theodore the 10 year old has been
so upset over that fish and i know that
obviously as as a young kid going
through something like that and as a
loss
but i know it's magnified by all of this
that we're going through you know the
deaths in our family yes but the fact
that he can't be a normal kid i mean
he's going to remember this for the rest
of his life it's just a it's a year that
they have lost
and the teacher thing i mean
you know i haven't talked about this a
lot but you know my 10 year old had an
issue with the with the online learning
he
he just was not able to really
process the information through the ipad
and it was getting to the point where he
wasn't learning anything
and so we put him in catholic school
because they they were going to school
the teachers were there they were in
person
and we made that decision because he
just was having such a hard time doing
this remote learning and i talked to so
many parents that are worried about
their kids that went through a year of
this that really didn't learn much of
anything
yeah and it's so disappointing i mean
you know i love our teachers it really
is a noble profession right but the ones
that
you know didn't get vaccinated or
continue to not go into schools well why
are you why are you a teacher then have
you have you been concerned at all with
critical race theory in the schools of
course
of course have you seen anything like
that
you know i haven't uh i i worry um you
know listen
i grew up
i grew up in canada
and you know i my best friend was indian
and but i never
you know looked at that i never looked
at her by the color of her skin i would
go over to her house and i would i would
love to learn about her traditions and
her family uh
and you know now nowadays it would be
like well you have to you have to
acknowledge the color of her skin and i
am of the belief that you know what i i
want to be colorblind i don't want to
you know judge somebody my
by my color or their color you know and
i know that that's taboo to say that
these days isn't that the progressive
position from the era of civil rights
that's what they wanted and now the kids
are going to school i bring this up just
because you mentioned the ipad learning
stuff and a lot of parents were finally
seeing their kids were learning this
crazy racist and not just racist stuff
critical theory in general encompasses
all aspects of identity
and then decided to send their kids to
private schools to catholic schools so i
was curious of that no but i will say
that that has been one thing that we've
been able to see online you know i you
know watching these online courses you
you see these teachers how they really
are you know we're lucky because i i
believe that in our school district they
they're in it for the right reasons and
but man the stuff that you are seeing
some of the parents that are you know
calling out these teachers
i mean unbelievable so maybe that's a
silver i mean that's the wrong word
silver lining but maybe maybe that is
something that you know we're now paying
attention to because of this
i think it's you know a lot of people
don't like to say something like this
but you know when god closes the door he
opens a window or something like that
there's there's always you know you look
on the brighter side things like that
people don't want to say that because
the pandemic's been so brutal to a lot
of people but it's it's that it's never
just black and white if there's
something that came out of this that
could be at least in some way considered
to be beneficial it's that parents got a
warning
about you know what was going on
teachers were freaking out you know
early on in the pandemic they were
there's like a viral video where one
teacher was saying we have to make sure
the parents don't hear what they're
telling their kids how do we deal with
this these zoom meetings are so bad
because the parents are now figuring out
we're teaching their kids this crazy
stuff that's creepy the parents should
get a pamphlet being like here's what we
teach your kids
and the parents should be able to go to
their kids and say what did you learn
today apparently they're being told
don't tell your parents i told you this
creepy indoctrination
yeah the one thing that i will say that
i will remember this past year is i've
been at home you know i've been i
since for a year now i've been doing
weather in a spare bedroom in my house
they
made a green screen i never thought it
was possible you know like a few years
ago people say oh why don't you just
build a green screen in your house and
you don't have to go in and do the
weather anymore and i thought oh that's
never going to happen well here we are
um the one thing that i will say is just
being at home and seeing my kids every
day that's something that's been very
special to me you know um
i i i'll love this year for that very
reason just to be connected to them
working from home is incredible i
started in 20 2012 and never looked back
i can't ever we tried the office thing a
little bit but what the commute i mean
an hour a day two hours a day come on
what a waste of hours in my opinion i i
love it i do i mean i miss going in and
me you know seeing my friends and my
co-workers
but i'll be honest if i could do this
for the rest of my career i probably
would and you but you would go out and
talk to people on the street too and
everything yeah of course i do miss that
yeah i do
yeah i hope that we get back to that
regarding kids that are having trouble
learning like you were talking about um
i think was your son earlier do you know
if are the schools being like lenient
about this are they passing kids through
without getting good grades that's a
good question um
i think some are
i really think this has been a lost year
for a lot of children i really think
that some kids should you know
go through the same grade again i mean i
don't think that that will happen but
i saw you know my child go through this
just you know
trying to focus on the screen and not
being you know my
theodore is somebody that needs to be
interactive with people and have someone
in front of him sort of you know
showing him um so i i really think that
i had to do the right thing and get him
back into school because that's the way
he learns the best and it's a private
catholic school so you're probably
getting
i'm not trying to disparage public
schools but i imagine it's better
in some ways yeah i mean my other son is
still in the public school but he had no
problem sort of doing that transition at
home so i have one in the you know the
public school which i i love i was
brought up in the public school system
um but for my other son who needed to
have that uh interaction and i will say
the catholic schools did it better do
you do you think that this whole zoom
thing has been harder on boys because i
know they have such a greater like level
of energy i think that there might be
something to that but you know i'm not a
psychologist but i'm sure that you know
they could probably tell you i'm sure
they'll be doing studies
after this
they're uh they're saying no more snow
days anymore
that's as a person who does the weather
boo
yeah what's that all about well it's a
snow day right you're in school and it
snows and then you're sitting there
staying at the news and then they're
like there's
well so so when i was a kid
we didn't use the internet you know back
in my day we had the tv
and it would be snowing and it would be
a couple inches we'd have the tv on and
they'd be announcing school closures and
we'd be like
and then they'd say you know mark twain
elementary yes
and then we went outside make snowballs
and throw them now they're like and the
schools that will be doing remote
learning today in the storm will be
can i tell you a secret uh that happened
with my kids and i was like you're off
sick today
i love it
that'd be cool if they gave kids like
one day a month that they just didn't
have to go in or something that's a
great idea but they they do i mean there
there's holidays
yeah but like the kids choice a kid's
choice there oh something that's a great
idea i think we need more of that
actually maybe more than one maybe like
five and non non-consecutive days where
a kid can choose to take a uh you know
a permitted absence yeah yeah but they
start to do the homework or whatever the
so getting on to this tangent we talked
about the fact that i took my family to
aruba and it was great but i will tell
you
uh just going through the hoops of the
covid tess
you know getting the kova test
beforehand
then going to the airport and having to
check your luggage and going up to the
the ticket counter and them checking
your documentation to show that you got
the kova test and then you know if you
don't have it online my husband had it
online and they were like no we need to
see the paperwork
and thank goodness he did the paperwork
because they didn't want to do the
online thing so you're in line for two
hours you know socially distancing to
get onto the the flight we went through
like
several security checkpoints to show
them our documentation to get on the
plane you finally get on the plane then
you arrive in aruba
and the same thing you've got to show
the people at the airport that you have
your documentation and then they give
you passes so that when you get to the
hotel you have to show them the past
that you got at the airport to prove
that you had your kovid test
oh it was i mean listen it was lovely
that we were there and we were able to
go
to a beautiful place for a few days with
our family um but the hoops that you had
to go through and i think a lot of it is
political theater
um i'm i'm
lucky i'm grateful i get to travel
around the world before
all these lockdowns and everything you
know in the past 10 years i've been to
dozens upon dozens of countries that a
lot of people aren't going to be able to
do anymore
i mean it's it's not just about getting
the tests some of these places require
you to spend like two weeks
yeah and like two grand up front
people aren't gonna be able to travel
my i haven't seen my mom in over a year
and a half because she lives in canada
still and and it's not good there she
was in lockdown uh very recently because
she lives in ontario and the numbers
were going up so they you know they
basically said you were housebound for a
month you know we do we do the zoom time
and stuff with her but i mean
i worry about you know her not getting
out you know she's almost 80 years old
and she's a fit 80 year old and the
other thing about canada
is that they have been terrible with the
vaccines
terrible
my mom just got her first dose and she's
almost 80 years old wow what was the
problem
the canadian government
you don't say yeah they don't seem to be
doing all that well
no i mean a lot of people
i think canada and their health care
system needs to be more of a story here
in the u.s to be honest with you
i
have ms i was diagnosed with multiple
sclerosis 16 years ago and a story that
i tell people is that i was actually
almost diagnosed in canada but they told
me i had to go back to the u.s to get an
mri because i would be on a waiting list
for over a year
to get an mri
to be diagnosed yeah one of my friends
brought her dad back to the u.s to have
cancer treatment because they were going
to put them on a list too it was going
to be something like four months when
you have cancer you don't have four
months canada's great
if you're healthy and you don't have
like a chronic illness
do they have private health care too
does it do they mix it up i i you know i
i would guess that you could probably if
you're wealthy you could do that or you
just come to the u.s
if you're
dirt poor or homeless i'm sure you'll
take a wait list over nothing
i guess however in the united states
emergency rooms have to admit you
but there there's still some
complications
i i don't want to get too personal but
there are some stories you know i know
with people in my life where they they
were stuck in canada wishing they could
get to the united states for proper
healthcare treatment because in canada
they don't have the same level of
technology
that is correct
part of the reason the mri machines is
because they didn't have
them
wow yeah
yikes
i mean listen i i grew up there i have
fond memories of of being in canada
but as somebody who has a chronic
illness uh and to have we really have
the best health care in the world
when did you when did you leave canada
uh i was in my mid-20s what made you
want to leave or what made you sad you
know uh career choices uh i felt like
you know i truly believe i'm one of
those people living the american dream
because i wanted to be a broadcaster and
i felt in canada they kind of put a cap
on what i could do well you know you're
doing the job that you should be doing
right now and you really can't go much
further than that
whereas i felt like you know i applied
for a job in new york city and got in my
car and i didn't have much money and
packed a suitcase and i moved to new
york
but um man having to be surrounded by
all of those those evil white
supremacists at fox news must be just so
difficult i'm kidding
i know you are you know i've been there
for the viewers though i've been there
18 years and truly it's like
they're like my family i you know i've
made some very good friends there and uh
and i feel really lucky to work there
but you're in new york yeah i've i've
heard from many people that a lot of the
people who work at fox news in new york
are actually liberals
well you know to be quite honest with
you no one asks who the person voted for
like when i went for my job interview no
one asked me who i voted for or you know
uh whether i did identify as a
republican or you know a democrat that
was never
asked and you know i don't know who
actually you know what i
the people there are some people that i
work with that i know are not republican
but i it doesn't matter
yeah as it should that's that's that's
the way it should be
but i was talking to somebody uh i've
been in
in and out of the fox building i've been
on jesse's jesse waters show quite a bit
and uh
so people were they were telling me like
it's new york what do you think you
think the people in new york city are
all a bunch of conservatives so of
course they're like liberals who work at
fox news but these are the people that
might be liberal but working alongside
conservatives don't view them as you
know nazis or whatever stupid lie the
other media outlets are pushing
but
i guess the name of the game today in
media is
hyper partisan tribalism
and it's it's the weirdest thing that
you know growing up
fox news was the bad network you know
bill o'reilly and sun goes up sun goes
down you can't explain that kind of
stuff and now
for whatever reason maybe it's just
political or maybe something really
happened fox news is the outlet actually
bringing on opposition voices actually
having challenging you know
conversations
and the other outlets are just trump
sucks
the right are bad people fox news evil
right well those raiding it's not
raiding anymore though the trump sucks
stuff
right i mean
what what are they going to do next they
got a they got to think of another plan
well they tried going after tucker you
know brian stelter over at cnn was like
tucker is the new trump and no one cared
i see what they were trying to do you
know they they had cnn had this really
long streak of trump sucks and it did
really well for them in ratings without
trump they need to find a new
villain they tried tucker didn't really
work because
tucker is not the president i saw
stephen colbert the other night was
doing a trump bit i'm like
really just oh yeah you need to google
that
yeah
did they come up with like a list of
names for him names for him i'm thinking
was this taped uh like six months ago
right but no it was like something very
recent yeah it was awful so a month ago
they did the nicknames thing colbert
asked viewers for newt
knew he paused this
music colbert asked viewers for new
nicknames for trump and they didn't
disappoint
on april april yes they totally did i'm
sorry it's so bad on april 17th
isn't he a comedian shouldn't he be
coming up with like new stuff well
that's novel
wow yes what were some of the nip
nicknames i don't know what what he got
here let's see he who shall not be named
eric's dad is that it i don't know they
know well can i tell you that gutfeld is
actually doing much better in the
ratings than any of those hosts
what does that tell you he's funny yeah
or they're just sick of the old same old
thing i mean you turn on any one of the
hosts you get the same joke yeah i went
on twitter and i looked at like uh
stephen colbert actually yesterday and
then i was like you may also like
samantha bee
uh what other all these like the same
jimmy kimmel uh oh i can't even think i
don't even want to well jimmy kimmel had
on michael and dell i thought that was
pretty good actually i i don't know if
it's just like and i ain't saying the
liberal media but the liberal economic
order the liberal international order
was created in 1946
the word liberal this whole idea of like
these people being fed this information
to promote american imperialism i think
those people are whether they realize it
or not part of it
no i agree with that i think
the reason why
all of these late-night hosts were in
lockstep is that donald trump was a
rogue he was not in line with what the
the the administrations of
of the past wanted
it's funny when you look at a lot of the
wartime policies of many of the past
presidents and it was expansion
expansion expansion middle east
expansion and then trump was just
roguelike no we're getting out i don't
want to do it
he didn't support him they loved him
when he bombed syria and so what happens
is all of the mainstream lightning hosts
are in unison trump is bad
there you go i so i don't know about a
liberal liberal economic order but it
was
let's get rid of this guy
i think the problem now is
a lot of these these people like like
like colbert
they were they were riding the ratings
wave
ragging on trump was just
making them money and it was working and
now trump's gone do you think that they
if they could would they bring him back
just to make money
so i was i was i actually went on brian
kilmeade's uh show when he i don't know
if it's a show but he's hosting prime
time
and he asked me if trump
started his own social network do you
think they would try and get him banned
and i said i don't know but i kind of
lean towards no
they want trump on social media so they
can talk about them to get ratings
now trump ended up launching just a
website which is not a big social media
platform so i don't think anyone really
cares
what's interesting is that trump emails
me like five times a day he loves you i
mean i got he emailed me he's like tim
take a look at this this photo of me
golfing it's the best no no but but he
emails everybody on this list and like i
got an email and he said he was golfing
and i'm like
i don't care that you're golfing
apparently nobody else did either they
try to write these stories but trump
isn't the president anymore so they
might as well be writing some guy did
something yeah who cares
i like how hollywood is kind of eating
its own though i'm enjoying that yes the
fact that they cancelled the golden
whatever it's called golden globes
golden globes yes they canceled it yeah
it's not going to happen next year
and
ellen degeneres is gone oh she likes her
shows canceled yes wow she's out
did she retire well that's what she says
she says it's just not challenging
anymore but we all know why it's because
all the stories were coming out how she
was not a nice person yeah yep yeah
people are saying that she lied about
being invited to dakota johnson's
birthday or something and i'm like i
gotta be honest i really don't care i
know but let's just turn the show off
you know yeah
the centralized hollywood system is is
cracking and falling apart i'm good with
that though yeah i used to like the
oscars way back when i would you know i
would stay up i would watch them i
thought it was funny
and now i could care less yeah the
golden globes are gone they're gone they
got they got cancelled
they say uh it was hardly a far far
foregone conclusion the controversy has
been mounting for months the la times ex
exposes in february highlighted the
association's insular culture and open
letter and stuff yeah woke stuff yeah
good if the oscars are going to go
they didn't do well this year the oscars
yeah it was like 58 down but has anybody
seen any of those movies
i don't even know what they were talking
about right no but they're doing this
diversity initiative where it's like
we could we could bring out you the
actors you know and love who are in the
movies you know and love or or hear me
out
obscure films
by
non-white actors
now i got no issue if they want to uh
if you know if they want to give awards
to people who aren't white i don't see
it as being an issue in any capacity the
problem is when
they start
they make something that doesn't
that isn't recognizable to anybody in
the country
pulling up movies that no one's seen or
heard of i don't know who's going to
want to watch that and i'm not saying to
be disrespectful i'm not saying it like
these people should watch it what i mean
is
if you've never heard of it why would
you be interested in it now if they had
seen the movie earlier in the year they
might want to see if it'll win the award
but then i guess people were shocked
that um
who was supposed to win
uh chadwick boseman i guess yeah was it
was it him like that yes and then they
ended up giving it to somebody who
wasn't even there uh anthony hopkins
yeah he wasn't even there is just a
disaster they i i think i i think it's
fair to say get go broke
they've they've put so much in the
basket of prioritized wokeness and
activism that the product is missing you
know i can't look at robert de niro
anymore because of his support for
andrew cuomo and billy crystal
oh it's sad to me i i i miss seeing
actors that don't tell me who
they voted for right isn't it weird
though that actors who probably would
never have thought twice about you are
now probably sitting around their
friends saying that you know oh you you
you fox news employees are evil fascists
or something and it's like
it's just weird to me to have watched
mark ruffalo and all these movies for a
decade it's hard go back to the avengers
before any of this insanity and i'm like
really cool hulk great mark ruffalo and
chris evans then they start screaming on
twitter and i'm like what is wrong with
these people wanna change the world just
talk a lot get involved in politics i
did get into a little bit of a fight
with ben stiller oh really yes on
twitter because he was supporting andrew
cuomo and of course this is going
through this the whole time where i've
been a bit of an advocate on behalf of
my husband's parents and
they were doing some event for
raising money it was ben steller whoopi
goldberg
billy crystal de niro
and they were doing this online thing
where you could meet the governor
through zoom and you had to pay like a
thousand dollars that goes to his
re-election campaign so i went on
twitter and i was like
whoopi goldberg ben stiller uh billy
crystal did you know that
governor cuomo put over 9 000 covet
positive patients in nursing homes
you know i i did it because
that's what people need to know about
right and ben stiller
came back at me and was like
oh miss little miss sunshine just
because you don't like him doesn't mean
you know i like him and he said
something about trump he assumed that i
was a trump supporter
so i went back and was like well i just
want to let you know that you know my
husband's parents died in you know in
nursing homes and i feel that he was
partly responsible and you should know
about this before you start raising
money uh on behalf of you know
dead new yorkers uh because of covid
and he i guess
did some research wow and afterwards you
know
went back and said i'm really sorry for
your loss i lost my dad earlier this
year i didn't know your story um i'm
gonna delete my tweet wow
i'm a i'm a fan of ben stiller you know
what me too i have been since the ben
stiller show in the late 80s good for
him
any artwork anyway even even if he came
back and was like i you know i i'm sorry
to hear that but i disagree and i like
cuomo i would have respected that as
well absolutely and you know at the
beginning it was a it was a gut reaction
you know like you're a trump supporter
um and then doing a bit of research
realizing what my family has been
through he had empathy
and for that
i mean i'm grateful yeah uh in in your
work
are you overtly political not at all
i've never been a political person yeah
ever i always say the red and blue that
i see on a map are areas of high
pressure and low pressure yes
i mean it's like awesome that's how
insanely tribal it is that someone
tweets at you hey this you know this bad
thing happened and the immediate
assumption is that the you know
meteorologists from fox and friends is
clearly
politically aligned and yeah
i hate being in this position but you
know i feel like
if i'm not going to talk about it who is
going to talk about it you know well the
crazy thing is
they demand
it's just
i tweeted criticism of biden you know i
said something like i guess build back
better means crumbling infrastructure a
crippled economy and escalating middle
eastern conflict and then i get all of
it clearly it gets a ton of retweets
because conservatives are like yeah
biden sucks and then i get a bunch of
liberals being like yeah well donald
trump and i'm like yes yes and donald
trump continue now
biden right
no
it's the craziest thing that
if i criticize biden right now the
responses but trump oh yeah same with
the cuomo thing too every time i go on
there but trump i don't see you blaming
trump well you know what trump didn't
put covet positive patience into nursing
homes
trump is trump uh trump needs to take
responsibility for different things he
trusted too many bad people in a lot of
different ways we we mentioned john
bolton being a bad choice especially for
his agenda trump trusted bad people bad
things happened it's not the same thing
as what biden is doing by all means if
you want to criticize trump i'm like yes
donald trump fired 59 tomahawk missiles
into syria we're very upset about it now
as for joe biden because he's the
president today
the problem is you know you go back to
the trump administration and i try to be
fair i supported i supported trump in in
november i said here's his agenda items
that i thought were really good school
choice was big i thought that was
fantastic he was talking about ending
the middle eastern wars and he'd
actually make moves to do it and i was
pretty happy among other things banning
critical race here and stuff i said okay
i'll vote for the guy i have no problem
saying that but i was also critical of
him in a variety of ways one he ordered
a commando raid that killed an
eight-year-old american girl and i
believe it was yemen 59 tomahawk
missiles mass spending
throughout the throughout the uh the
four years of trump you have a media
that's lying
over and over again about russia and
other ridiculous nonsense
so if i'm going to be accurate i'm going
to be defending trump whether it's about
policy or otherwise i have to be like
that's not true
but when trump did something wrong i'd
say yeah well i don't like that trump
did this and boy was it stupid to hire
bolton that was like the worst thing i
think he could have done
now
what's happening is biden is president
they're not they're not reciprocating in
terms of fairness
biden needs to be heavily criticized but
these people who claim you know a lot of
these leftists who are socialists want
to claim that they don't actually like
biden they
they jump to attention the moment
someone criticizes the guy it's the
stupidest thing ever come on we're in
the middle of of a very high inflation
people are getting scared and the media
you know yelling comes out there's
there's no inflation problem then a week
later the new york times well
inflation's a problem here's what we've
got to do about it joe biden then says
we're going to keep printing
unemployment checks which chamber of
commerce says is contributing to the
unemployment problem
and then they're gone defending joe
biden who's not a leftist who's not a
socialist and i'm like why are you
protecting this guy again i thought you
didn't like him but he was better than
trump now you're actually standing up
for the guy let's be reasonable
the buck stops the current president you
want to blame trump for covid my
response was we don't have a control
group by which to judge the metrics you
know of of trump's responses
but i think certain certainly if you
think trump didn't do a good enough job
i'm willing to hear your criticisms okay
now joe biden is president you want to
talk about what's going on well he's the
president so the buck stops with him nah
they never played that game it's always
you know the economy was doing really
well under trump what did they say
actually this is obama's recovery
efforts and trump's just riding now the
economy is doing miserable well donald
trump
every single time that's exactly how it
goes
i love reasonable people
yes they're rare
nobody's perfect
i don't i don't know i think the system
itself is really faulty and here i am
enjoying this delicious citrus surge the
aoc says it's racist you guys are
surging together right yeah yeah what's
going on over there
i'm kidding aoc didn't say that serge
citrus flavored soda was racist she said
the words that's right that's right i
was like wait sir are they a sponsor no
no no no no we are not sponsored by
surge okay i just i i like having
obscure uh
things i love that yeah i mean the fact
that you brought up rc cola yes i hadn't
heard i had not heard that name in a
long time so when people are downstairs
like anything to drink you want a surge
or an rc quarterback people are like get
a tab really
if you have those but that's exciting
you brought excitement back into my life
i wonder what other like weird 70s 80s
and 90s products did you have a slushie
while you were down there i heard about
the slushies slushies are good but yeah
i was talking about a slushie machine
gotta be close okay yeah yeah i was
going to make an apple juice
the next time it's working
i'd like to be invited yes oh yeah yes
well you can come by any time we'll get
the slushy machines going heck yeah
bring the family the kids will love it
they love it jokingly
we do have search it's you know because
i think it's hilarious but uh you know
aoc when when she said that serge was
racist
it's a perfect example of in-name
tribalism i don't want to rehash an old
story i was just mentioning we had the
sodas and it kind of plays into it but
she recently was talking about israel in
gaza and then somehow said
we don't want to recognize the plight of
palestine because it would make us have
to recognize the plight of the the
migrants on our own border what and
everyone was like what
you know i think it might be because she
doesn't really have policy positions
maybe it's just cliche or stereotypical
for me to be like ah you know aoc
doesn't have anything going on but i
really do feel like you know in this
culture war in this political divide
i mentioned in a moment ago the
uninitiated and the initiated they are
people who are just democrats so the
democrats must win no matter what you
can criticize cuomo for doing something
horrible but their democrat and team
democrat must be protected at all costs
sad you must be team trump
it's like okay i mean look i voted for
the guy but i don't care if you smack
talk the guy if someone comes to me and
says yeah well trump did this that and
this i'd be like damn that's awful wow
yeah well biden you know as well he's
the president now so so let me write
down all the bad things about trump i
agree you're right and uh now let's talk
about biden right they don't want to do
it because this is the nature of
politics just what team are you what
which team are you on
of course fox news is is team orange
well you're wearing this edge
yes too red and blue areas
low pressure high pressure
it is it is fascinating the whole
network is like
well actually you know
it's interesting that there's one
network basically i guess there's
there's on newsmax but in terms of you
know large viewership
all of the other outlets walk in
lockstep
fox news is the only outlet that
actually has conflicting narratives or
opinions well and that was the
brilliance of when it was invented it
was because there wasn't anything out
there to represent the views of the
viewers
right i mean there was the cnn but you
know cnn back then was different
it's not the cnn that it is today very
boring yeah i was like c-span kind of
i always got a mixed up when i was a kid
like they both just have video of
congress just talking
is that what they did back in the day
seemed like in the 80s that's what cnn
was
i mean
they they had people on the ground and
stuff
but it was very boring
msnbc is doing better than cnn which is
quite incredible
really is that is that not the case
historically
no i i i mean for many years cnn was the
oh yeah most valuable whatever it was
called the most trusted name in news i
guess and then uh msnbc was always the
third but
now more than ever they're they're being
you know you've got but you've got
somebody like a rachel maddow
who is
nuts stressed
i watched her last night in her face
she was the one saying about the masks
that she couldn't she couldn't bear to
get rid of the mask yeah she's like i
have to rewire my brain to not see
people how to mask as a threat i saw
that and i was like i've never viewed
someone with or without a mask as a
threat
i just mind my own business i go to the
store i buy the cat food and i come back
and we give the food to the cat i don't
know what you're talking about lady
it's it freaks me out that people think
the way she does yeah and they watch her
show so clearly they do
that's it's really it's really scary
because if people start to be afraid of
each other that's the ground up
totalitarian mentality because then it's
very easy to manipulate people to do
things to each other to your neighbor
turn your neighbor in like in the soviet
you know gulags two out of five people
were informants
and then you have a chris cuomo who
doesn't want to wear a mask ever
but tells people they need to wear a
mask or who fakes being in quarantine
fake quarantine
yep
wow i loved it when ben smith at the new
york times actually called out cuomo
and nothing happens of it you know what
very recently on social media um someone
called him out on it and they referenced
a fox news article talking about the
fake quarantine and he was like oh well
you shouldn't believe fox news
i went underneath and brought that
article up by ben smith and said hmm
this is not fox news right and there's
actual proof of a guy that saw you in
the hamptons not quarantining it's it's
it's insane to me and brian stelter i
think is one of the worst people on tv
because he provides cover for them as
this media reporter who's constantly
i'll tell you this
i i've known brian for a long time not
like i've known him well or anything but
it's amazing how he went from being a
media reporter for the new york times to
the fox news review show for cnn sunday
mornings
that's what he does he watches fox news
and then he writes about it and does a
show where he's like tucker carlson had
an opinion about waffles today and it's
like i did if i want to hear tucker's
opinion i'll just ask him he did a whole
piece on the fact that fox news
personalities weren't admitting that
they were getting
the vaccinations like they weren't doing
their vaccinations selfies did you
violate policy by speaking on this show
that you got the vaccine well i put it
out there i actually put my vaccination
on social media because i'm very open
with having ms and i'm someone that you
know should get the vaccine just for
that very reason that i have a
compromised immune system so i was out
there and i put it on social media and
then of course he's like well there's no
fox personalities that are putting out
their vaccination selfies and i i just
was like i did this three weeks ago am i
not a fox and friends personality you
know
you are
but it's bad for their narrative so well
we don't mean the
the meteorologist the weather lady no no
no no we mean uh the uh
pundits
hannity
we want hannity to do it that was weird
when he did that morale it was like a um
like a brow beating or like a like a
what would you call it like a morality
where it's like well
yeah like a guilt by like we got the
thing where is everyone else getting it
like a peer pressure and at the time
when he talked about that
a lot of people weren't allowed to get
the vaccination because there was a
hierarchy because of andrew cuomo who
could get the vaccination so
stelter puts it out out there on social
media like why aren't these [ __ ]
personalities going to get vaccinations
but at the time we actually couldn't get
them because we weren't
a lot of them weren't of the age or
wasn't it specifically why aren't they
posting vaccine selfies yes what the
so i don't know if you're familiar with
freedom tunes at all no uh so our friend
sheamus he has a channel on youtube he
makes these little uh he makes his you
know political uh cartoons and one of
them is a guy going to the doctor to get
his vaccine and the doctor is like do
you want to take the vaccine selfie and
he's like no no i don't need a self and
he was uh okay
and then later on kovid shows up at his
house like the actual virus and he's
like i'm here to get you and the guy
goes kovit you can't get me i've got a
vaccine and he goes what show me your
show your proof and he shows him the
vaccine card he goes
not that i want to see your vaccine
selfie everybody knows you know so
that was the plan cnn my head is
exploding it's just ridiculous if that's
what you're bugging us about not having
a coveted vaccine it's also a health
issue you know health information you
don't you don't necessarily have to put
that out there at all why are you brow
beating people for
because putting health information out
there they they want to push the
narrative that all of fox knows his
viewers are anti-vaxxers or they
are conspiracy theorists or q and on or
whatever the stuff and it's it's not
true
i have been at home broadcasting
you know in my spare bedroom at my house
for over a year now and when i went in
and said listen i'm compromised i
probably should stay home they were like
of course you need to take care of your
health and you know
they've always been like that it's
really
disappointing i guess to say uh creepy
if you watch cnn
and you never watch fox news they
probably think it's a bunch of people
walking around in clan hoods with covid
and other diseases and like no vaccines
and
there's just like this uh hive of scum
and villainy in new york city surrounded
by gates that no one can get into or
something because like people got to
realize that fox news the like uh the
building you work out
particularly is in new york under the
rules of cuomo and de blasio so
certainly they're taking it seriously
because they legally have to
what's the history of fox do you guys
know much about it like how it got
started when it got started roger ailes
he was the he was the mastermind behind
fox news and um
he was uh
he helped a lot of um political people
uh with their careers in politics
um and he was the one who kind of
decided with rupert murdoch that there
needed to be uh
uh a television
station cable news network that
represented people that didn't feel that
they were being represented
and so that was um
i think almost 25 years ago it was like
95 or something i think i you know i'll
have to do some rooms i mean i've this
is my 18th year so i think we're coming
up on 25. so yeah murdock had started
fox
like fox had been around for what since
the 80s or something
fox like the the fox tv show is that
what it was and then ales came to
murdoch and was like let's news channel
okay yeah
i'll have to see the chicken or the egg
is isn't fox news like uh is it still
owned by murdoch it's because it didn't
go with fox and the disney deal i guess
so it's like no we're our own separate
entity now how is it working at fox news
i love it i've been there like i said
for 18 years it's the best job i've ever
had
um i love the people there uh i love the
job that i do you know the fact that i
talk about andrew cuomo is you know
i've never thought i would ever be in
this kind of position talking about
politics because that's not you know my
wheelhouse at all you know they don't
they don't uh have an issue with like
you coming on shows like this and
talking you know i think that they knew
that this was very personal for me they
knew the story
and at the very beginning when this was
happening my husband who's a very
private person um not in broadcasting at
all he didn't want me to bring up his
family
you know they were very private people
but when we saw the fact that there was
no news out there
and the governor was going around as the
go-to pandemic politician not talking
about these nursing home issues
it just it became more and more clear
that he was getting away with this so
you talk about tucker i was texting with
tucker and
i believe um
it was a conservative uh
was it uh town hall maybe
forgive me but it was a conservative
outlet that that that broke the news
that he wasn't counting those that died
in the hospitals okay i think it was
town hall i think it was town hall too
no what's what was the outlet that
tucker carlson started daily caller
daily caller it was a daily caller
forgive me so they were the ones doing
the investigative reporting and i was
reading this and thinking to myself why
isn't this a story on the on the news
channels so i texted with him and i said
listen this is what happened with my
in-laws um
he he put covet positive patients into
nursing homes he actually had a mandate
for 46 days to do this um this should be
a story and and i he said listen if you
want to anytime you want to come on the
program i believe it's a story
you have a forum to do so um and when i
continuously saw the governor going on
these programs and never being asked the
nursing home question that's when i said
to my husband you know
can we can i talk about this because i
don't think
there's anyone doing that uh and so
that's how it sort of began
and i haven't really stopped i'd like to
but uh
it's still to this day you know he seems
to be getting away with it i think he's
gonna get away with it i mean maybe
maybe he won't get reelected but i don't
think he's gonna get in trouble but you
know
you don't think so
yeah what about the harassment you know
i started maybe
you know there are a lot of democrats
that don't like him and so that's why
when all the harassment stuff was coming
out i thought that that's why they're
jumping on this bandwagon because they
they the the really criminal stuff is
the nursing homes but they can get
behind the metoo
uh stuff because that's a little bit
easier to digest i guess to go after the
governor for the me too stuff
um but i mean there's nine women now he
keeps going on and and putting his
you know his his foot in his mouth
there's a an apparent impeachment
process going on with uh albany
lawmakers but i don't i think it's a
sham so maybe you're right but you know
what
if it means that he is not re-elected
for a fourth term
then
then it was worth something i guess
but i just
i don't expect any of these people to
ever be held accountable what if it was
a republican governor what if it was a
ron desantis that put covet positive
patients into nursing homes
nine thousand of them he covered up the
numbers he tried to sell a book for four
million dollars
you know prison right he'd be in an
orange jump dude probably not prison but
the the media would it they would run
for six months now it would be the top
story on every single cable news channel
this is the problem with
the the networks have built an audience
based on tribe because
i think mostly because of the internet
if people can choose to watch whatever
they want then they're going to choose
to go where their bias leads them so
cnn becomes the orange man bad network
now
everything they say has to be in line
with one particular world view
their ratings are in the gutter on fire
because they've pigeonholed themselves
but i think they probably would have
went under a long time ago if they
didn't donald trump allowed them to stay
afloat for several years longer than
they should have
people watch that watch that network
or they used to just to hear
why trump was bad to prove to themselves
that he was bad now that trump is gone
what does cnn have to offer i mean they
used to go and do reporting they don't
really do that so much anymore i think
they're trying to again but
well to back to your point uh you know
fox has been really good to me and when
they knew my personal story and knew
what i was trying to do by going on you
know tucker show and sean hannity show
and fox and friends
it was to be a voice for all of these
families that didn't have one so i do
walk that line sometimes um and i'm
grateful that they gave me the platform
and trusted me that you know i was doing
it for the right reasons
you went on tucker's show and talked
about all this was that the first time
you had stepped away from just doing the
yes and it was terrifying it's still
terrifying yeah it's kind of it's kind
of it's kind of crazy i mean your
whole persona on fox is you walk outside
there's people there and you're like
how's it going welcome to new york yeah
like how you like ask the kids like
what's it like in new york and then here
you are in this very serious political
fight also on tucker you know i can be
both of those people you know i can
still be the one that goes out there and
has fun and you know does the kentucky
derby and uh groundhog day and and write
the freddie the frogcaster books for the
kids but i can also be a serious person
that wants to
um you know hold the governor's
feet to the fire and and try to make him
accountable for something that he did
wrong and that cost the lives of
thousands now everybody wants to know is
tucker a nice guy he's a lovely
wonderful guy yeah he's a good friend he
really is well so you also mentioned
earlier on that the kentucky derpy is
that it is yup so the kentucky derby was
uh two weeks ago uh and
this tomorrow i'll be at the preakness
which is the uh they call it the second
jewel in the triple crown so if you win
the kentucky derby and then you go on to
win the preakness and then you go on to
win uh the belmont stakes which is in
new york that's the triple crown there
hasn't been many of them i believe
there's been 13. um and so
tomorrow that's where i'll be at the
preview
are you just there to hang out and watch
yeah no i broadcast from there oh okay
so i get to do fun stuff like that uh so
i'll do the weather forecast but i also
i really love the hor the horse racing
you know it's uh one of the first dates
my husband and i went on was at belmont
it wasn't the greatest uh
date
um where's belmont belmont is in new
york that's where the triple crown is
actually held yep and uh and then uh
we've been to saratoga a couple of times
so um
i don't know it's it's fun you know for
two minutes
the country comes together no one knows
who voted for who you know
you look at a horse that's that's
running a two-minute race and there's
excitement
have there have there been any pushes to
politicize any of it
i know there's like the drug thing but
that's that's own scandal it's not you
know political thing well i mean i i
guess a lot of people might say you know
what's happening with the drugs scandal
is
the top trainer i would i would say
arguably he is the most famous trainer
in horse racing so you know there is
going to be a lot of scrutiny on this
guy
um
but i mean it's the horse
betting on horses
heaven forbid they find out he voted for
trump or something then it would just be
like everything we feared is confirmed
right yeah but you know it's good to
hear that there's there's pl there's
sports stuff happening that kind of
escapes all this i think so we got the
olympics coming up
i guess there's like 350 350 000
signatures to get the olympics banned in
tokyo because of kovid then you've also
got the uh what was it called the ipcc
is that the international no is it the
idea that that sounds right no i think i
got the i'm not sure no that's the the
panel on climate change
what am i thinking different i don't
know the olympic committee or whatever
the i o pc uh they're they're banning
politics they're banning you know black
lives matter and stuff
so if you're competing you can't you
know raise a fist or drop to a knee or
something but if you're doing interviews
you can say whatever you want and i'm
like i actually think that's a good
thing you know we've we've we we are we
are boiling over
in this country in around the world
partly because of social media i think a
lot to do with social media and media
everybody's at each other's throats
everybody needs to just get back to
arguing over which sport team yeah i
agree yeah i agree
just to watch a baseball game you know
but now it's like what are they doing in
new york like the vac section and the
unbacked section oh well that's cuomo
again yeah yeah yeah you got your
vaccine you can sit over here and if you
don't have your vaccine you got to be
over here six feet apart i i'm like oh
i'd like to pretend i don't have a
vaccine so i don't have to sit next to
everybody yeah exactly i get i get more
space yeah i can put my coat over here
that sounds excellent yes you know
what's really fun when you get the cup
and it's got the bowl on top and you've
got the chicken nuggets and you're
holding the cup you ever see those
things no no what's that so there's a
cup it's full of soda and then they put
the lid on they put the straw and then
there's a plastic ring that goes over
the top with your fries and your chicken
nuggets or whatever that sounds
fantastic so you're holding a cup you
can drink it and then
yeah it's great
you need to get some of those here yeah
it's actually a good idea
people could have like their drink on
the show with like chicken i don't know
they have chicken nuggets on the show i
guess if you would like or like i don't
know empanadas
i do
the venezuelan maduro empanadas
oh no what's that i was giving a speech
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait hold on yeah this is good his
people were starving and he was giving a
speech but continue yeah and he would
just in the middle of his speech pull
out an empanada out of his jaw and take
a big bite as he's talking to this these
starving people the people of venezuela
are starving
and he's looking at the camera and he
just reaches into a drawer and pulls out
an empanada and really wants him to pull
an empanada one of these days
i would love to get a little empanada
thing here i would like a drawer then
randomly i'll be like looking at you
while you while you talk and i'll just
fight it just put it back
i don't know if i can handle that
yeah but but
when i was younger
i was really frustrated with sports
because it felt like all this bad stuff
is happening around the world and no one
cares because they're like oh the
raiders versus the whoever i don't know
what raiders are football
and so i'm like nobody cares
now we have the inverse problem i'm like
people care too much yeah slow down a
little bit you know like go watch a
football game or a
baseball game
in canada to have a hot dog yes yeah i
mean we got hockey but no you know
canada it's it's hockey it is it's
hockey if you don't know how to skate
you you know you need to go somewhere so
you're really good at skating i'm a tear
i used to figure skate but i haven't
done it in a long time is it because
canada is like a block of ice
[Laughter]
basically although i will tell you that
my kids learned uh to skate you know
because of you know growing up in canada
i'm like you gotta learn how to skate if
you're half canadian you need to
strap on the skates they just they just
naturally have the ability to do it
one day your kids handed a hockey stick
and they're like
you know
i'm just i'm i'm good with them just
learning how to skate they don't have to
be like do they rollerblade gretzky's no
they don't
tim's been rollerblading a lot i know
yeah do you love it oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm an old man so uh
35 i'm older than all of you people
well we're old
well i don't know
well there's there's solar age and
genetic age okay so you can go around
the sun a million times but if your body
stays super youthful oh i like that
there you go perfect fantastic
telomeres of your of your chromosomes
young at heart yes i think one of one of
the funniest things i've seen is like
you know uh janice you're very
straightforward
you know wholesome
meteorology and ian's this like trippy
spacey guy tranced out hippy
before the show started ian was asking
janice like have you ever like looked at
the collective conscious of
electromagnetism affecting the sky have
you ever used your magnetic field to
interact with the clouds because i have
i was just wondering if you had lydia
what did you get me oh i'm sorry you
dispersed
the negative energy with positive energy
i'd imagine you don't get questions like
that all that no i was afraid i was i
was like oh my gosh i was in san diego
one year and there was this giant storm
coming in black on the on the radar yeah
and we laid on the beach and just
meditated and focused on it and the cl
the clouds parted above us and the storm
went to the north and the south but it
didn't it it went around us i've had
multiple experiences like that really
like dancing on my roof and like doing
tai chi and then the clouds start to
spin and open up and you can see the
moon and there's this thick cloud cover
because sometimes clouds move sometimes
they move but they're light uh negative
energy force so and we have magnetic
fields i just thought it was funny to
like ask a meteorologist about using
your brain waves to like change weather
and we were talking about sprites above
the clouds when lightning strikes you
see energy go out into space oh my gosh
that really happens though
i mean he showed me a picture on his
iphone oh there you go yeah i trust i
would like to go deep on sprites one day
okay
you could teach me a
few things
solar energy i wonder where it comes
from like galactic is it universal the
sprites yeah
what's caught where why is it going out
it goes out into space which means it's
going
somewhere
another dimension yeah it's probably
going up into the torus do you believe
in aliens well i think they exist yeah
it seems likely but i don't think
they've ever been to earth okay all
right
we're going there let's do it we got the
story from the daily mail u.s navy
pilots say they saw ufos off the coast
of virginia so frequently they got used
to them branding them a worrying
security threat former navy lieutenant
ryan graves called the unidentified
aerial phenomena a threat to national
security i am worried frankly no if
these were tactical jets from another
country they were hanging out up there
it would be a massive issue
louis elizondo a former official with
the defense department said that ufos
appear to have far superior technology
to what the u.s has now
the government is expected to release a
report in june on ufo sightings after
unclassified videos of them were leaked
to the new york times in 2017. senator
marco rubio called for the detailed
analysis after he viewed classified
briefings on uap
while he was the head of the senate
intelligence committee so uap is the new
word for ufo oh uh
this is this is interesting they saw
them so frequently that they branded
them a worrying security threat
you asked ian but i had to interrupt do
you believe in aliens i think i do
you think you do
yeah
we do what do you think they are
well do you think the ufos are are
aliens or do you think it's you know
russia oh gosh i don't know about that i
do think that there are other life forms
out there
i certainly think so yeah massive
universe of course as for whatever these
things are
it's probably just right you say it's
the daily mail where yeah the daily mail
dot co dot uk okay yeah
they love this stuff they do yeah either
this could be
a false flag like the us government is
like we don't know what this is it might
be enemy this it might be security this
that and they're just testing you know
drone craft they raided tesla's
laboratory and he was working with like
long-range power distribution and like
i don't know i thought i thought you
were talking about elon musk for a
second they rated the tesla factory i
was like oh that's hilarious
what was he doing with that nicholas the
fbi i think was the fbi when nikola
tesla's laboratory and um was award the
warden cliff uh they demolished warden
cliff which was his like big power tower
that he was trying to elect like charge
batteries from a distance with now see
that's because the aliens made him do it
you know well he used to say he would
get communication from uh like
intelligence beyond what we understand
tesla the guy who had radio basically
how funny would it be if like there's
like these super intelligent aliens
and they're like sitting in their
spaceship above the earth
and one alien's just talking to another
alien about something just totally inane
like so the wife uh she wants to take
skiing lessons the other alien's like
are you sure about that and then tesla's
sitting there like fiddling with the
wires and then it's like cheer
in there and then he hears the
microphone like so my wife was saying
ski lessons and then he's like what is
this i'm hearing who's talking and the
aliens are like oh he can hear us whoa
tell them something something smart real
quick right yeah no they're like quick
shut it off call the fbi rate is
greatest compliment my guess is that the
government raided his laboratory took
the technology and then they've been
experimenting on it ever since and they
have these light weight i don't know man
like to people prop up tesla as if he's
just like
from the future or something you know
he's pretty smart yeah yeah but
a lot of really cool stuff you know
davinci had a bunch of weird pictures
too and they don't do anything awesome i
was just studying that guy a little bit
yeah he's cool dude he used to sleep
like 20 minutes every four hours all the
and then he would take four hours away
sleep for 20 minutes four hours that was
awful yeah he would sleep two hours a
day
yeah i know i'd be miserable yeah you
get almost into what is it rem sleep i
think it takes 90 minutes to get into
rem sleep yes we got no rem sleep
apparently is that why literally such a
great artist yes
constantly having waking dreams he would
draw with one hand while he was writing
with another
yeah incredible human
an alien
from the future
you know you know with all these
conspiracies i think people just want to
believe in something crazy because of
course because otherwise life is boring
it's the unifying theory that you're
talking about with sports like we need
something collectively to focus on to
take us out of the this and that you
said he said she said aliens is a good
one space travel's a good one that's why
people love elon musk so much i think
it's why people also want to believe
that
you know
every fox news host is a bad person or
every person on the right is grifting
and they don't actually believe their
opinions it's easier to believe in a
world where there's a grand conspiracy
against you and an evil villain running
everything that is to accept that you
might be wrong
or that you know life is more nuanced
than this i think there needs to be more
ben stillers out there who like listens
to the reason of why somebody did
something yeah does a little research
and says
huh i'm sorry for your loss i'm going to
take down that tweet the so i was uh i
commented on someone's facebook page or
something it was like
they were talking about we're fake we're
in the middle of the biggest general
strike because people are walking out of
these jobs and i said it's really
interesting how in republican areas
people like where they're getting rid of
these unemployment waivers the strike is
ending and then it it came to someone
just immediately responded with some
tribal comment calling me a grifter or
whatever and i said maybe maybe the
reason you guys believed in russia was
because you couldn't accept that your
policies were bad your candidate was bad
and because you couldn't accept that
truth you need an excuse as to why
hillary lost in 2016.
so you make up a reason instead of just
accepting people wanted trump more than
they wanted hillary it's the same thing
right now they'll say you know people on
the right they're all grifters or you
know fox news is a bunch of far right
whatever because it's easier to believe
that there's an evil presence as opposed
to accepting that people might disagree
or they might be wrong when it comes to
ufos and things of this nature it's just
still in line with the conspiracies
i don't think people want to accept that
life is routine and boring
think about life in you know the 1600s
1700s
all you did was wake up farm and go to
bed wake up farming go to bed maybe
that's why they want to keep the masks
right they don't want to go back to
normal
it's they like the masks it feels it
makes them feel like they're part of
something that's that's right that's
bigger yeah and now it's going away it's
yeah
that's like their security blanket yeah
you imagine there's no villain i mean i
really think there is no villain there's
no villain it's just the universe is is
terrifying and hard to live in they're
fortunate to be on earth where there's
an atmosphere i think there are bad
people i think evil exists
but
it's not it's not like you know actually
i would say thanos is probably a good
example
he's nicolai thanos no no thanos from
marvel you know in the movies at least
he thinks he's a good guy but he's
really dumb and that's a lot of what we
deal with in terms of villainy people
who are guided by what they think are
good intentions but they're really dumb
yeah and they do dumb things and tim i
would push back on the argument that
life is really boring because it's only
boring because we have so much privilege
like we don't have to work our butts off
we don't have to like go get water from
the well we don't have to worry about
heating our homes or having not having
plumbing and stuff like that that's
really you know that's boring i was i
was looking at some of the magic cartons
that we had you know magic the gathering
is
it's a it's a strategy fantasy card game
okay so you have a deck of cards and
there's like a card like a vampire on it
or something you know i was looking at
some of these cards and i was looking at
trolls and goblins and vampires
and i started thinking about like where
these stories come from i read once that
vampires come from rabies the people
would be hydrophobic because the rabies
their their gums would be you know
pulled back so their teeth look bigger
and they'd bite you and then you turn
into a vampire and zombies was the same
myth i don't know if that's true
but i think about these stories of
dragons and whatever and the story of a
dragon probably was some dude who was
like from somewhere in like eastern
europe went on a journey towards asia or
whatever and at some point i don't know
where the komodo dragons are native to a
monster
saw a giant lizard
and then had a sword and they like
snapped at him and they they bashed it
and they were like this is crazy they
ran away
drew a picture of it and then said there
was a gigantic lizard and then someone
sees that and because they didn't
actually see it they see the picture
they're assuming it's this massive thing
well i've got i think maybe like a
dragon giant dragonflies that had like
flint in the back of their throat and oh
get out of here what are you talking
about they could spit a flammable liquid
and then and cause a spark and cause
like a flaming spit i'm just don't laugh
too hard there's a beetle that spits
fire i know i know but
i'm laughing because what i'm talking
about is
if have you ever seen the picture of the
first sighted elephant from like the
european colonists went to africa
whatever saw an elephant
and described it and then someone drew
this ridiculous picture of what they
thought an elephant looked like based on
the description of it
when they set the first platypus back
people in europe i guess they thought it
was a joke that they stitched this
together
so i'm just what i'm saying is i see
what you mean you look at these legends
and it was probably like i fought a
giant demon monster right and it was
just a grizzly bear that's kind of like
astrology like when you look at the
constellations and they make up stories
about it's an archer a center like that
they've done that to animals in the past
too i know there were like giant bears
like 18 foot tall bears or 16 foot this
even the snub-nosed bear which is only
like 13 000 years ago that it went
extinct it was like i don't know 16 feet
tall or something huge monstrous
creature
so i would imagine in the past like
giant snakes and huge spiders that over
time either couldn't sustain or we
killed off
yeah i guess the uh the theory is that
there was a lot more oxygen back then so
these things could get a lot bigger so
we had these really huge mammals that
are absolutely terrifying and i'm not
sure about the gigantic snakes but i do
know that there's like these really
really big critters that are absolutely
horrifying to think about now like we're
again we're so lucky to live at a time
when we're at the top of the food chain
because these animals are scared of us
and we've like taken over bunches so
we've wiped out the threats now like
where's the threat it's in our dna
and we've turned on each other for the
most part we haven't i try not to right
but there's a tendency maybe the reason
we're seeing more and more aliens is
because the political divide is getting
so intense about to blow each other up
aliens are coming they're going to
intervene oh my gosh yes that's it would
you go to mars
of course
it's a one-way trip though oh yeah no i
don't know
i would definitely think of something
like that that'd be awesome why not
i i find it really scary to think about
going to mars i find space to be
absolutely intimidating like i wish that
we could explore the earth a lot better
before we try and go to space but mars
is really interesting in theory would
you go like to the bottom of the ocean
before you went to the moon uh yeah
actually i probably would i think all
the fish at the bottom of the ocean are
fascinating there's nothing on the moon
nothing lives there we have no idea
that's not true
we all know the nazis escaped to the
moon oh my gosh you're right you all saw
that movie how could i
obviously i'm joking i'm referencing a
movie called iron sky but i just love it
if media matters is like tim poole
thinks nazis are on the moon and they
pull the club false
false not yes snopes are nazi's really
on the moon false tim poole is wrong
all right let's go to super chats
if you have not already smash that like
button but smash the like button
thanks for hanging out on this friday
night we're chilling and uh we're gonna
take your super chats and uh so we're
gonna get some questions from the
audience oh wow yeah i see a lot of
chats were saying they were so excited
to see you on the show oh that's so kind
absolutely
was that my mom no no no just their
actual audience yeah she's a huge tim
pool fan oh is she really yeah oh thank
thanks for watching and being a fan of
the show
so
jesus flores says i am a gorilla oh
if you would uh you go to timcast.com
click the store button and get one of
our shirts you'll notice in the chat we
actually have the doge to the moon shirt
with it's it's a sheba not a gorilla
maybe we should make one says amashiba
or something
jake everhart says just got a four month
supply from safe and ready meals thank
you for your recommendation and
journalism thank you very much for
supporting the show appreciate it
matthew
kirschner says tim i've been trying to
get a hold of you about your ram's
extended warranty i hope this is not the
super chat you finally read i've been
trying to contact you with about iraq
love the show
yeah i'm getting two calls uh
consistently from someone named charity
call and scam like i just gotta scam
likely
i wonder what he's up to best friend
they call me more than anybody else scam
like they care sometimes i'm sitting
there and i'm lonely i know people are
naming it and i know
yes
opossum says tim please watch the new
saw movie and do a review on it on
monday's show uh-oh why this is a new
song i hope it's not woke saw's bad
enough
oh hey frigsby with a massive super chat
he says great guest janice dean the
weather machine is awesome oh that's
kind there you go the weather machine
the weather machine shepard smith gave
me that name oh really yeah
first day i think i was on air uh no you
know what we were doing rehearsals
and they wanted me to sort of be a
regular feature on shepard's show uh at
3 p.m and so we were doing some
rehearsals and i could tell he's a smart
guy so that the wheels were turning
right he's like janice dean janice
janice d in the weather machine
i love it how much how much uh how much
like uh how many minutes on air are you
every day that's like well it depends
right i mean no not i wouldn't say a lot
like on fox and friends it's at least
once an hour because i do the national
forecast right now if there's a big
story if there's a hurricane tornado
outbreak that kind of thing it's it's a
little more than that
um
but yeah i mean
i don't know i guess you know i'm lucky
if i get like a minute 30 during my hat
yeah but you're like you have to be
there plugged into the machine the whole
time
you nail it yeah absolutely and then you
have to be prepared too because it's 24
hours right so if there is like a
tornado that kind of you know hits a big
city like atlanta
oh absolutely yeah yeah people don't
realize that they assume that uh you
know when i was on i was on rogan's show
last time last year
i mentioned that i was like i record
like three hours three and a half hours
a day and he goes that's only three and
a half hours and i was like it's like
eight hours of work production research
and then three hours of me recording
myself talking and i was like oh yeah
that's right i'm like
but you know
a lot of people don't realize because
they only see you on tv for a minute
they assume you show up for a minute
then you walk out the door and you're
gone
and then i have other stuff i mean we've
got like fox news radio that i have to
file for we do uh you know
foxnews.com got to make sure that the
weather is up to date on that too so
yeah i wish i could say i do like a
minute 30 and then i'm out of there
wouldn't it be great to get paid tons of
money to show up for a minute and leave
wow it's like what i do
but it shows it shows trust me you can
tell all right the curly afro says i see
all this discussion that's not financial
advice on btc and ethereum but ian
leaves out one of the most one of the
most fastest most secure chain-link and
decentralized blockchain that dwarfs
dwarfs them did you bite digi apes
together strong diamond hands hodl is
digibyte anonymous like uh
monero i don't know i just know that we
do get a ton of super chats from people
being like this is the one true
cryptocurrency and i'm like you mean the
one true that that you bought i'll tell
you one i don't talk about a lot chain
link which i really like i don't really
don't know a lot about it which is why i
don't talk a lot about it but here it
enables interoperable blockchain
experience
keith porter says ron desantis and tulsi
gabbard for 2024.
tulsi has the vp
interesting i mean i'd vote for it
balance yeah
the median says though it might not be
exact there is a book that said two
thousand years ago everything happening
now would happen i don't know when it
will happen but get ready for the seven
worst years of your life matthew 24 and
revelation by the way what's your
favorite flower
uh i don't know mine's the rose
rhododendrons rhododendrons yes that's
just the only like obscure flower name i
know i don't think it's obscure which is
a weird name i like the terpenes and the
rose huh it's a similar uh chemical
that's in the marijuana plant terpenes
that stinks what's your favorite flower
i don't know that's a good question i
like all flowers oh i love dendillions
what are those pandillions they're
gorgeous
yes i'd like to make some dandelion tea
oh
do you know what the state flower is for
maryland is it a dandelion no it should
be
i don't know what it is it's all over
the place
it is a black-eyed susan oh what is that
yeah it's a
is that named by like some dude who beat
his wife or something no oh my god it is
a member of the family asterace which is
daisy so it has like a rocket shaped
middle that's brown and the powder
you're not even reading this no i like
that i love that
flowers yeah she knows easy she
introduced me to succulents the other
night they're so cool
succulents yes michael bell she's like
be gentle with them you don't touch them
too hard yeah they're the best
all right seth rowe size of the sun says
tim often mentions he doesn't mind
wearing his mask or understand what the
big deal is i can't wear a mask due to a
medical condition and i've lived as a
second class citizen for over a year
with no end in sight it's very different
from what i say though obviously i'm not
talking about people with medical
conditions and it's it's a challenge i'm
talking about people who don't have
medical conditions and are just like oh
haramph i won't wear a mask
i mean like walmart makes you wear shoes
they make you wear a shirt they make you
wear pants they make you wear a mask i
go to the store i get in my car i put a
mask and i walk and buy my stuff i walk
i take it off i just i'm not really
really bothered by it i don't know
i i think it's an issue of
for some people
personal sovereignty and pride
like i refuse to bend the knee in any
capacity and i'm like i'm more of a
strategic
get the you know accomplish the mission
and if the mission is i want to buy some
freezer pizza
and yeah
i don't call it bending the knee i call
it like
when when the ninja wants to assassinate
the feudal lord
he doesn't complain that he has to
pose as a peasant farmer i shouldn't
have to dress as a peasant farmer i'm
i'm a ninja warrior no he's like i must
dress as a peasant warrior to sneak in
the neighborhood bends the knee for the
prayer he does everything that he's is
expected of a peasant so that he can get
close to the to the feudal lord and then
strike so it's like i'm going to go in
and get my pizza you know what i mean
that's it ninja sounded really good it's
just it's just not it's a mission you
know but but i i have certainly have my
limits you know what i mean in terms of
like being forced to bend the knee for
things that are a violation of your
principles i'm sorry like i have this
little mask with a beanie on it and i
just go like
oh it's solid yeah it's not really
ruining my life by having to do that if
someone said
you know literally dropped to your knees
i'd be like you're my when joe biden is
like get the mask you know get the get
the vaxxer else i'm like shut up joe
biden i think that's a case of choosing
your battles that's just right yeah like
you wear a mask it's not that big a deal
but other stuff bigger stuff if people
can't you know i get it right yeah
all right let's see what we got
matthew's scotty snyder says we are so
lucky they were only able to hack our
oil pipeline computers remotely from
5000 miles away and not our voting
machine computers their physical access
to
well the people in russia who did this
didn't have physical access to any of
these things
but
i think it's fair to say that our
critical infrastructure is extremely
vulnerable and we definitely need a
security revamp
oh
don't jump on youtube taz riot says wow
a can of surge haven't seen that in a
while amazing guest as well oh yeah i
think i think you know uh we'll get tab
next
okay but tab is diet isn't it it is and
it doesn't taste as good as this is
great crystal pepsi that's what i want i
don't think you can get crystal peppers
oh really was that a face that was a
thing why why was that a thing i don't
know but sprite remix was also a thing
that was actually really good i would
like to come back
does mountain dew code red still exist
yeah i think so don't they have it at
like taco bell they have the baja blast
at taco bell i don't know what was it
citrus soda like mountain dew that came
out uh mellow yellow yeah is that about
no that's been around for a long time
super long 97. sierra mist yeah that's
it yeah the fake sprite
thanks sprite
all right let's see where we at zachary
koenig says tim love your unbiased take
on the madness going on the masks are
just the government's uh exercise in how
much control they connect they can enact
in the population
i i think for some people probably
there's corruption and exploitation of a
crisis i think a lot of people are just
scared
tin man says how do you feel about
hydrogen batteries
good
generally sounds like something up your
alley i guess the fear would be that
they could explode like the zeppelin the
hindenburg but
i hear they produce massive amounts of
energy
whoa this is cool
thumper says tim i make ethanol from
tree sap and cattails to run my vehicles
my channel is about is about how to do
that can you give me a shout out what uh
thumper yes why don't you send us an
email
at uh have you been yeah i always check
spin the ufo spin the ufo gmail.com
because that would be really cool to do
a project because uh making ethanol from
tree sap that's awesome that's pretty
cool cat tales i love those things yeah
what are those are those like the the
brown yeah with like the brown soft
stuff at the top of the stock you can
make ethanol from those things
fascinating wow
ethanol is the stuff you can drink right
yes menthols you can drink with your
grandma ethyl but you cannot drink with
your grandma methyl oh my gosh that's
how i remember
ethanol is you can drink methanol you
can't i think a better way to describe
it is your grandma ethel will give you a
back rub and make you until you joke so
you laugh and feel good and your grandma
methyl will stab you in the eyes with
forks that's better actually
there you go
two golden baby says it would be great
to have a spotlight shown on murphy if
uh if new jersey was a country they'd
have had the highest per capita deaths
in the world his nursing home order was
the key driver for that before that stat
we were in new jersey before coming out
here uh last year and it was just so
awful i was like we gotta leave new
jersey was bad real bad i mean
bad in terms of what the what he did but
just i mean we do you know about that
gym i tell us where they yes we opened
we lived only a few miles away from
those guys
the cops had no problem going in and
arresting you know arresting some guy
who came out and shutting them down and
really creepy stuff happened like squad
cars were seen according to some
witnesses blocking off the alleyway that
went behind the building
and then they found and then the next
day the gym flooded and they found paper
towels jammed in the drain behind the
building
so people are questioning why they were
cop cars blocking that off and then the
next you know then a flood happens
apparently flood happened more than one
time as well
just very weird
maurice says if we
if when we get covet they say stay home
for two weeks why is anyone scared they
literally treat you by letting your body
heal itself a vaccine seems unnecessary
if it doesn't stop you from getting it
well i mean that's why i just say talk
to your doctor
i i don't people go to the tv for their
their you know medical advice
i don't think fauci is
knows what you need
there could be somebody who's like got
kidney problems
and vouchers on tv like just go and get
it it's like hold on like you know your
doctor's gonna be like well you've got a
kidney thing so maybe you shouldn't or
whatever
dr fauci thought um governor cuomo did a
really good job with new york too that's
all you need to hear
so
just
man
the democrats really love their tv
doctors
you know dr oz yeah they love their tv
doctors
no no no no no
no no
no he has a doctor written something but
he's not a medical doctor okay like a
psychologist yeah he says i think he's a
clinical psychologist or something i
think so too ryu kirito says vote for
major williams i think will be great for
ca you should try to get them on oh okay
i don't know who that is
oh talking mud crab says i much prefer
casual janice over dressed up fox anchor
janice i didn't even recognize her wow
maybe because i have my hair back oh
nice
yeah love it casual janice
i love being casual janice
seems a lot more fun yeah is that what
you do at your house all the time
i mean
the that all that
stuff hair and makeup is oh man
i know right right right right we don't
know what it's like we don't do any of
that i just sit down on the camera that
is awesome
or whatever
i can't i mean i well i started my
career in radio i loved uh the fact that
i could tell a story and my mom wouldn't
email me and say did you get your hair
cut
you could like walk in in like a
sweatsuit and your hair's all messy and
you're like it's been amazing well you
know doing weather from home has been
great because you get they can only see
me from here so like i've been wearing
pajama box
the whole year yeah there was that
really awful photo of brian stelter in
like boxers or whatever boxes and socks
and they thought it was good like cnn
was like we're gonna show this like no
don't don't show that that's the point
is no one's supposed to see it that's
why you know but i don't i i don't i
wear pants i guess it's not hard dress
like a heel not worried about it
but uh i remember you know what when um
well i'll say now it's it's been really
great with covet because i went on um
uh prime time on fox with brian kilmeade
and a van just pulls up no makeup
nothing i just sit it's a van with a
camera in it it was really cool and you
know i get requests periodically from
fox for like coming on and commenting i
usually most people send me requests i'm
just kind of like i'm too busy for this
stuff but when i was living in jersey
they would send me a car instead and
then bring me to the studio and just
paint my face they'd pull out a paint
can and just be like right the the
airbrush did they do the airbrush
no i never got that yeah
oh yeah it's like it's like spray paint
oh my gosh
they would
they would compliment my face
and the woman who did makeup would be
like wow your face is so good you look
so young and then they would just like
plaster
yeah right shellac and then afterwards
they would give me an alcohol wipe and
i'd be like
i need like 10 more of these to get it
there are some men that will go outside
afterwards and not take it off
i have to but you can't get it all off
right away you have to take a shower
yeah they give they give you the alcohol
wipes afterwards and i'm like wiping
everything off and i'm like can i just
keep
it's like it never stops it's like your
face is a marker and you're like jeez
i'm sorry about that experience
i don't care though
you know your skin looks great let's
plaster it it does look great your skin
does look great yeah that's right they
just like jealous
they're like well we gotta stop it from
shining so we're gonna little powder
yeah i'm really impressed though i'd
like have like a blemish or something
and they'd be like we can erase that and
they would like that's cool yeah like
wow it's incredible the air it's called
an air gun
to get rid of it we should do it
um the makeup from the spray oh
it's an air it's called an air gun i
think yeah an air spray it's just faster
makes you look like a robot
when i when i would do the remote uh
whenever it's remote they don't do
makeup is that that's like normal i
guess i guess you have to do your own
yeah when i went on tucker it was remote
and i didn't they didn't do makeup just
put me in a room and
there's a camera it's like i don't care
whatever
um but jesse waters it was like
i got the makeup he's definitely made up
cause he was in studio and i'd be
sitting there he admitted to that
jesse yeah i don't know if he uh he did
but when i went on i've been every time
i go on a show i think i've been on a
show maybe twice or three times they
just you know lather it up right and
then i walk in the room and sit down and
it's fun the age of leds has made it
easier because when the halogen lights
were so hot if you ever sit next to a
house man it's just a meltdown
and hdtv
changed everything that's when we really
had to like slap on the stuff because
you know you
the hdtv they could see every pore it's
like zoomed on your face oh yeah it's
terrible yeah all of a sudden everyone's
like wow that's what they look like but
the lighting the lighting has gotten
better
i was telling lydia that i would love to
have like a necklace that has the
lighting so that it always comes up like
this quickly from the bottom oh that's a
good idea yeah million dollar idea
balance the downside that's a good idea
right i love it yeah there you go a
lighting necklace
that's a big deal yeah it's a pretty
good idea right that's great every woman
over 50 would buy that i would buy that
like invent the product let's get it
crystal
yeah maybe pretty yeah all right james
oren fall new yen says my kids school
district in our area of virginia does
not hold failing failing students behind
in what seems to be
residual of no child left behind
also we are only a few counties away
from luden hi janice hi
mr toad says you all need to check out a
channel called late layton
lay tentacles
like tonic please yeah i'm going to go
with greek his analysis of white
fragility in particular his videos are
getting age restricted it'd be nice if
we could help him out check him out
billy two-cent says merriam-webster
recently changed anti-vaxxer to include
people who are against
government-mandated vaccines oh and
please have karen strong on the show she
said she'd come on if i badgered you
well all right we'll look into it
tin man says this winter i want to go
see grandma what's my parents and
sisters
grandma did not give a flip about the
chronovirus because in her house she and
her ki she had her kids her grandkids
and her great-grandkids interesting
john curry says god bless you and your
family janice serial senior slayer
andrew killer cuomo is the most prolific
serial killer in american history wow
you know he has never said
like i'm sorry for your loss or any of
that he has zero empathy
you know he could have met with families
he could have written condolence cards
instead of that stupid leadership book
at the very beginning if he had
apologized and said you know what i made
a tremendous mistake and i'll spend the
rest of my days you know trying to write
this and it'll never happen again
instead of going on television with his
brother and with a giant giant q-tip oh
yeah
that's actually the day after that
program when he had the giant q-tip
that's when i went went on tucker
carlson right i was so
angry wow that they continued with their
comedy hour
cuomo um he doesn't have empathy he has
uh the opposite what is it uh contempt
oh and disdain vitriol for regular
people i just i don't think he has any
of that
empathy at all i just think he's missing
something maybe
i mean look at what
cuomo
locomo did when he faked the quarantine
and he comes out of the basement like
this is it i'm out it's like shut up you
lying prick so sad
you gotta watch that clip and watch his
son's face because his son's just like
right really dad
wow i just love the guy on the the fat
tire bike who blessed him right he's
funny he's like
chris cuomo aren't you supposed to be
quarantined yeah that guy's a hero
donald glover's story
failing awards woke may hold
institutions but the culture is shifting
people realize that art requires bravery
and moral authoritarianism stifles
creativity definitely yeah i like it
ryan c says billy passed the third grade
oh what a glorious day oh past the third
grade the billy madison way hey there
you go
right on
uh c i was this corporal
corporal hillbilly says tim and gang not
asking for financial advice but where
are good places to get into the crypto
game also don't forget michael knowles
new book speechless controlling words
controlling minds
i just figured out you can buy uh crypto
on mines yeah you can buy ethereum
through you can buy everything oh you
can yeah because they have a buy crypto
button i actually was looking at that
last night and i just clicked it and it
was like oh wow but you got to connect
your wallet i actually like that better
than going to one of the exchanges yeah
i had some problems with coinbase and
they're because they're overloaded the
customer service never got back to me so
i i can't use that block fi i use and
then i move the stuff to
what's this new one that i got kucoin
that's another exchange but you can't
buy to kucoin you got to buy in at
specific places like block fine coin
base the clown world review says my
heart has been with janis dean for a
long time i'm sorry our society isn't
more understanding regarding your
in-laws too many tribalists nowadays
that's true
oh whoa mr crinkle says tim add jolt
cola to your fridge beverage selection
if i remember correctly it had twice the
caffeine of coke and that's great also
hey ian sub dude
jolt cola we should write that i'm
writing this down right now
there was a story about the last
blockbuster yes and they set up an area
of the blockbuster that looks like a 90s
living room so you could rent it on
airbnb and go and hang out with your
friends and watch a movie
so i had an idea for a
you get like a three flat
and then the first floor is the 70s
second floor is the 80s and the third
floor is the 90s and then people can
airbnb and what you do is you can
actually set up like the specific date
of when they're like your your stay is
you know 1994 may 1st
you know and the time is 24 hours and
then what you do is you turn the tv on
and you could actually get the old
archival programming so they could turn
the tv on that's awesome old tv yeah and
then you could like order food and the
guy shows up with 90s style like
dominoes or pizza hut and then when you
open the fridge so you basically buy all
the al alt refurbish all the old
appliances and then people can go and
people would totally do that i don't
need that right now that would be so fun
i want to do it i'd love to go to i
think you should do it the floor the
carpets the couch do you remember great
was it grateful or what were you going
to say no what no there was like that
that you got that drink and you like go
you like squish it up and down and it'd
be like a juice you could drink i have
no i think it's called i'm gonna look it
up interesting how do we do this i i
just i if this thing existed yes where
there was an airbnb where you could be
like the 70s 80s or the 90s i'd be like
dude give me the 70s room right now
that'd be awesome i've never been in a
70s room i was born in the 80s yeah it'd
be so cool i was born in the 70s
so in the 80s room you'd be like oh
that's huge
like rainbow bright stuff or whatever
definitely and if i could do my hair
like back then it was like this that
would be so bad
yes
i've got like huge i mean i have huge
hair now but it was like really big but
how cool we could we could take like uh
uh well like a raspberry pi in or
like a small computer yeah and then put
programming on it so that when you turn
the tv on
you have all the different channels you
have you know channel through two
channel five bunch yeah and and well
whatever program he was on at the time
yeah
back when life was so much simpler yeah
you'd be watching like the fall of the
of the of the berlin wall or whatever
oh yeah like that would be cool i
remember seeing that yeah you could do
that you could have like a newsy part of
it yeah yeah or or you could change a
channel and put on like three's company
or something three's company remember
that
apparently just watching john ritter on
sling blade he was very funny he was
great he was so good man he was great
yeah jolt cola jolts cola
i don't know how you'd actually get some
of these things like purple that's what
it's called
purple was like an accordion drink
it was good i gotta look this up
is it still available no it only lasts a
few years
rad number two says please take this 20
to purchase some rip it drinks ribbits
yes have them on hand for any guests
that fought in iraq and or afghanistan
they'll appreciate the nostalgia trip
what is rip it i was going to say okay
if you drink rip it in colorado springs
people will come up to me and come up to
you and be like holy crap i remember
this from when i was deployed because i
guess they got them in bulk for the
military people who were in like
afghanistan and iraq so that's kind of
cool i think that'd be really fun and i
know that you can still get it we used
to buy it at the dollar store so that's
a good idea what about fun dip remember
that yes yeah those are good right yes
all sugar
it was like a piece of chocolate it was
a chalk and you would lick it and then
you would put it in the sugar and you
just didn't eat it
i mean i think i remember one time i
thought that i could like make a
beverage out of the fun dip but it
didn't it didn't work i added water and
it no so there was something we used to
do on in chicago it's called happy and
you take a pack of kool-aid and a cup of
sugar
normally you you put a cup of sugar in a
kool-aid in the water and you start you
got kool-aid but you put the cup of
sugar and the and the kool-aid mix in a
bag and shake it up and then eat it fund
it like fund it that was your own fund
but when you were you know it was like
cheaper you know what i mean you called
it happy they called it well everyone
called it
that is really good
that makes me happy yes so people would
have like blue and purple bags and
they'd be like just like eating the
sugar yep and then but like you you talk
about fun dip pixy sticks were literally
oh tubes of sugar wow that's right you'd
rip it and pour the sugar in your mouth
remember
pop rocks i love that of course
i'm pretty sure all this stuff still
exists doesn't it yeah i'm sure it does
and remember there was like that um the
waxing stuff you're thinking about that
you'd bite into it and then the juice
juice would come out
they were like lips because you have big
league chew oh yeah yeah that was the
gum yeah that was that's definitely so
many good ideas i got it i got out of my
system
so somebody somebody super chatted in
reference to ian talking about roller
rollerblading and they said tibs tim
slides up hitting the backside machio to
unity flicks his feet and 540s out as
his inlines clack on the ground tim
wipes his brow he is pleased
uh i don't think there's such thing as a
backside macchio so uh
it's it's unfortunate really i saw you
riding a rail yesterday yeah we built a
20-foot long rail we want to extend it
to another to 40 feet
but uh we just got the the ground
resurface so more skateboarding is
coming back one nice one of the things
is that it was really hard to skateboard
in the parking lot it was never sealed
so it was really rough to ride on but
like bikes and rollerblades some other
problem but we're gonna have a scooter
guy come out so we're gonna get a a
scooter and then we're gonna have some
some scooter vids too
yeah i'm just we have the skate parks so
i've been skateboarding for a couple
decades we got skateboards bikes
rollerblades we're gonna get scooters
next what about a ferris wheel
a ferris wheel roller coaster awesome i
wish yeah but you know you know uh we
want to build what's called a mini mega
it's a very large ramp where you roll in
and then it's got like maybe like i
don't know how what 10 feet maybe so
it's this big ramp it's 10 feet and you
launch yourself probably 30 or 40 feet
you can get more play out of that than a
ferris wheel i guess what about
trampoline
that's a good idea yes yeah everyone
would love that i would love that but
but like an olympic grade one yes yes
where you can like
jump 40 feet or whatever oh my and do
flips
airbag
we want to get a big airbase i like the
way you think janice i love it we want
to get a really big air bag and you can
jump off the roof
i would do that
yeah yeah that'd be fun that sounds like
you just relax you just jump and you
slay and you relax and then
you know i gotta admit though it's not
as exciting as as it sounds
jumping off the roof jumping off a
really high thing into a pit or an
airbag because i've done it several
times
the first time you're like scared you're
like oh man it's gonna be so exciting
and then you jump and then it's like a
split second you're just laying there
like
i repelled down a building once for fox
and friends cool you can get it online
and i dropped a bad word on television
surprised
why were you rappelling down a building
it was it's a santa rappel that they do
every year in connecticut and uh and
they asked me to do it and my husband is
a firefighter i i i said to him i'm like
is this okay to do and he's like oh yeah
that's totally safe he's like no you're
supposed to say you're waving you don't
want your wife to go rappelling down a
building so i did it i dressed in a
santa suit and i actually did it with
brian cashman of the new york yankees
yeah he was he does it every year what
was this recently uh a couple years ago
oh okay you could google it i think i
saw this it sounds familiar
and i was you know it was it was
terrifying and i and they brought they
were broadcasting live on fox and
friends and i guess i forgot that i was
on television oh yeah well you know
judge jeanine was the one who called me
and she's like did you just say what i
thought
i'm like oh no
so i called my boss and i'm like i think
i might have said you know the f word
and then he's like oh oh okay i'll check
that out and my husband was like well if
there's ever a time for you to be able
to say that word it would be repelling
down a building what happens do you get
like fined or something no not at all no
it's just like a policy thing i think so
yeah yeah sam devlin super chats just
became a member at timcast.com i was
shocked and elated by all the cursing
can't wait for the weekly hangouts at
timmy p's yeah so right now we're doing
weekly vlogs
um
every sunday we put up a video of us
just hanging out or whatever but we're
slowly getting to the point where we're
going to do daily oh so there's going to
be like a reality tv kind of thing at
the studio of whatever shenanigans
that's awesome yeah yeah and not a whole
lot goes on when i'm working out the day
so it's just we need to get production
up to a certain level to where there's
always some weird thing happening if you
have trampolines and stuff there's
always going to be weird stuff happening
we have chickens
they're hilarious the chickens yeah
one's really mean
oh no what happened so
it's it's really crazy like only a month
or so ago they were so small they would
sneak under the buildings to escape to
run from us now they're massive are they
wild chickens
no i mean they're farm chickens you know
so we went to a farm we got uh we got
eight two of them didn't make it
and uh so vanessa is i forgot the name
of it is a plymouth something plymouth
barred rock yeah and she's really mean
yeah so the other chickens
used to be really really scared now
they're kind of chill i can walk up and
just put my hand and then you know pet
them and they'll like they'll stand in
my hand and then make funny noises
whenever i go into the chicken city it's
like this fenced off thing
vanessa will like stalk me and like
stare at me and if you put your hand
here she'll bite your skin and she'll
pull it really hard oh no yeah she's
mean she wants to love you no i think
she's trying to protect the rest of the
birds like get out of here she's the
she's the foe she's the rooster because
we don't have a rooster oh well there's
a pecking order yeah you know she's the
boss get it but roberta is a rhode
island red is that what it is rhode
island red yeah she's the biggest now
and she's got the waddle and everything
she like she wasn't the biggest at first
but now she's massive now she's starting
to put up a fight
so we're going to put cameras and we're
going to live stream 24 7. that's
fantastic people love that stuff and
then what we're going to do is what i
want to do is um
every time 50 000 super chats come in
have a machine automatically release
some bugs yeah so it's like we'll have
like a rotating wheel and then as soon
as the 50 as soon as the total amount of
super chats hits 50 it'll spin and drop
crickets and then the chickens will run
and they'll go eat the crickets oh they
like crickets oh they love crickets or
mealworms
and then people who are interacting by
watching live can be like i'm in a super
chat come on everybody super chat so we
can so you can watch the chickens in the
box that idea is that great it's an
excellent idea i agree we're so the
schedule for now is
this week we got guns
i'm going to stephen crowd you know
steven crowder yeah he got me a sig m400
from sig and it got lost in the process
but the company the store hit me up
saying we found this thing you never got
it i'm like i know there's a big there's
a
there's an issue with it so they finally
sent it out to us over here tomorrow
we're going to go film picking it up
finally me getting the gun that crowder
got me almost a year over a year ago i
think
uh and then on sunday we're going to the
range we're going to go to the range in
west virginia are you going to film all
of this oh yeah and we're going to put
it up on on youtube oh that's awesome
yeah yeah next week we're going to be
fixing a lot of the audio issues and
video issues and filming with some
scooter stuff and then i think the week
after that is when we upgrade chicken
city and then finally get the live
chicken city show it's good like you
need neon lights chicken cities
we have little houses and we want to put
addresses on them
yes
oh that's amazing does that sound great
yeah yeah
and then i think we're getting a rooster
oh so that'll be very interesting
tonight on this episode of the chicken
bachelor the chicken bachelor is having
relations with all of the available
women walk out with like a bow tie
[Laughter]
ceremony they love stink bugs they do
you bring a stink bug to the chickens
and they fight over it there is a stink
bug on there
they're invasive they're from china it's
a moth isn't it no no it's stick bug oh
um they're they're pink bug i think
they're actually kind of cute the stink
bugs they're right they're just if you
like you know poke them they you sort of
move and they don't bother you they
don't bite don't do anything like that
and if they're on the wall and you like
put your finger in there finger near it
they'll just jump off and fall to the
floor like they're brilliant
pretend that they're dead no they just
jump and fall it's the fastest way to
escape
what if you if you grab them and
threaten them they emit this nasty smell
have you done it before oh yeah you
don't want it really i mean
when you try to pick them up
if they get threatened it's just like
whoa but i handle them all the time and
they've never stunk at me that's good
because they're they're pretty chill
yeah they're super low-key
is it like a skunk smell no it's weird
it's just a strong odor there's a reason
they're called yeah it's musty it's like
it kind of smells like if you walk into
an old cabin that's like not been
cleaned in months and you're like what's
that smell yes but you throw it in the
chicken city and they run up and they
grab it they'll fight over it they'll
like try and rip its limbs off like the
stink bug oh they love them really yeah
it's like imagine if someone threw you a
burrito you know what i mean
yeah i would what i would subscribe to
that i really would we're going to
chicken cities might show on the list
love it they won't come home at night or
after school and they would watch that
so what we'll do is we're going to have
a like a gopro
they're all going to be synced in and
then once you know people could super
chat five ten bucks but as soon as every
every 50 increment it'll drop some bugs
and then you'll watch the chickens in
the camera go after the bugs can they
overeat is that possible yes but we're
not going to put that many bugs in okay
so it's like i'm glad you're thinking
about it you care about this chicken so
there's there's six which means if we
only had like 20 mealworms
then they're not going to overeat by
eating those meal worms and it would
rotate once and drop like four or five
of them and so there'd be a cap
but um
i i think we'd actually give them a
decent amount of bugs without
overfeeding them the thing about
mealworms i was reading is that chickens
don't know when to stop eating mealworms
because they're delicious they're like
golden they're called meal worms and
they'll get sick but if you give them
regular feed they're fine
and uh you know chicken city next show
on the list so the vlog and the chicken
soup i'm very excited about this this is
the best news that i've gotten
[Laughter]
lot more people will do it
yeah yeah and so the so uh i'll we'll
we'll show you the chicken thing we got
it there's a little trap door like a
another little trap
door well it's not a trap door there's a
little door you can pull up and allow
the chickens to go into the farm area so
we have half the lawn is like a farm so
what you do is after you harvest all of
the vegetables and everything yeah then
you let the chickens go in and just do
their business because they eat the bugs
and they fertilize it and then in the
springtime you let them back in again
for about a week or two two weeks and
they till the land and fertilize it and
then you can plant everything and it
grows it's better and so you have the
cycle of chickens and you know if we let
them out now would they eat the seeds
yeah they need ever they destroy it so
we don't want to do that but that's uh
that's that's the plan for the next show
and what about vanessa oh yeah yeah
vanessa she's a constant threat
she's mean she's the villain of the tv
program no yeah well actually yeah she
was pecking the other chickens and i was
like hey hey knock it off because she
was mean but now now roberta's standing
up to her oh good so it like we gotta
get this chicken city show on the road
because yeah it's drama that's dramatic
you can't tease us like this anymore
yeah
we have the tripod set up we are really
close to doing it but um we're going to
have someone come out to actually make
sure
everything's set up properly for the
chickens it has to be perfect yeah it
has to be perfect it does and then we
have to build the system for how to
dispense
so every morning we go in and throw like
a small handful of like 50 crickets or
something yeah and then they would just
be chilling in this little tube eating
food and doing qriket stuff and then we
just have like a little motor going
right
strangely calming i would think
for the perfect like very zen i think i
would oh yeah and then what so here's
here's another big uh piece of it uh i
need to hire a composer so anybody
listening we need somebody who can make
uh music
consistently all day every day once we
get a few hours worth of um some music
we're gonna make
lo-fi hip-hop beat beats to watch
chickens too
oh my gosh and then people can turn it
on and hear like music while they're
working and then watch the chickens just
you know chicken waves i know someone
who could do that for us all right well
there we go let's make it happen yeah
chicken wave that's um so you can you
turn it on and it's just
you know chicken's doing their thing and
you're listening to me
and you're like you know writing stuff
and
studying interesting exactly music so
people who are at work are studying well
there's that there's a really popular
youtube channel lo-fi hip-hop beats to
study two yeah yeah and there's like a
girl and she's drawing on a loot but
it's going to be this to chickens and
high def so it's huge your boys can do
homework oh they're gonna love it be uh
interactive and then another yeah yeah
it'll be the biggest show in the world
it'll get hundreds of millions of views
per day you say that but i think that
you're on to something chicken city yes
just live streaming the chickens city
how it goes
i'm stoked we don't have that many i
mean you go to one of these farms and
they have like 50 to 100 chickens right
but then you lose the intimacy we need
to be able to so the chickens are all
different breeds easily identifiable you
know who the roberta is you know who
sarah is they're all named they'll have
names that are chicken names like carol
clutch we'll get their bios up carol
they all need bios we should make uh
shirts for each of them yes and then uh
we actually one of one of the friends of
the show was like
you know i said you know he has chickens
i said are you gonna eat your chickens
he goes yeah after three or four years
when they stop laying eggs and i was
like we're not these are going to be the
stars of our show they live for about 10
years and you know his attitude was kind
of like oh wow
i guess i wouldn't think about it that
way and i was like no these chickens are
going to live the good life the best so
we'll have t-shirts and you could have
like you know team vanessa and team
roberta it's it's all coming together
yes chicken city
anyway thanks for hanging out oh my gosh
honestly this is like the best time i've
had in a long time hey thanks for coming
it's been fun it's friday night hanging
out talking about chickens to wrap
things up uh forever you better do it
because if you don't i'm coming after
you oh
we got it it's like 80 of the way there
we got the power outlet there
we have the link
we're gonna um we can wirelessly capture
all the video and everything we've
already run tests on it
right now we just need to
[Music]
it's it's it's not so easy to launch
multiple shows so the vlog is what we're
working on right now because we can vlog
the creation of chicken city okay maybe
we should have done chicken city first
because you get it live and you walk
away do a documentary on it
on the creation of chicken city yes
i need to know how this all came about
all right we'll we'll do a special mini
doc for the for the uh for the vlog yeah
and talk about it i love it chicken city
thank you so much for having me today
thanks for coming this has been a lot of
fun
so uh for everybody else listening smash
that like button on your way out
subscribe to this channel if you're
listening on itunes or spotify leave us
a good review
and we'll be uh we do the show monday
friday live at 8pm you can follow the
show on facebook facebook.com timcast
irl where you can share our videos to
help us grow and leverage the facebook
network to drive people to timcast.com
where we're trying to build something
special with chicken cities and vlogs
but other shows too the paranormal show
is on the list we're we're going as fast
we can hiring people is very very hard
quality control is very difficult so it
takes time but with your support at
timcast.com it's gonna be epic and we're
also on instagram at tim cast irl is
there anything you wanted to shout out
uh janice i mean you have books you're
famous for cities
chicken city
we have a big spokesperson we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna sample that if
you singing
and we're gonna make a song with it and
that's gonna be and uh and by agreeing
to appear on the show we have the right
to use you do whatever you need to do i
just i'm happy to be a part of it right
and i want to thank my kids
every time every time the 50 50 of super
chat comes comes in and the bugs roll
it's gonna yell you singing chicken city
yes
that's good i love it so is that what
you want to promote anything else
you know
i'm just here all right cool me and me
thanks for hanging out thanks for having
me shout out to stella stella what up
stella
thanks for tuning in stella yes thank
you guys for coming and you know me and
crossland follow me on mines at ian
crossland hit my ian girls.net if you
wanna and uh thanks for coming
send me some pictures of the lightning
oh yeah the sprites
super cool and you guys are more than
welcome to follow me on twitter as i
continue my journey to have more
followers and sour patch kids at
sourpatch lids
and yes we will get some chicken city
stuff going on chicken cities there's
two more super chats i'm gonna read um
because one is more business plum god
said tim i'm an algorithmic composer and
i make endless loops and variations of
lo-fi ambient beats send an email to
spin the ufo gmail.com and then i gotta
read this one from matthew schultz he
says why is tim talking about his
chickens more compelling than anything
on cable
and then vanessa stoller says team
vanessa of course yes
yes that makes sense
thanks thank you so much for hanging out
on this friday night and we will see you
all monday bye guys
you